foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on you guys uh testing
hopefully the sound is on yeah it looks
like it's on it should be well yeah it's
right next door you were you're an
expert in the video for a second I might
have been you're always in the video in
that store what are you doing over there
yeah
I already said the neighbors video okay
hold on you should be in this video you
got it you're fine you're you're well in
this video all right it's fine just
making sure
so uh today
Friday
we're kind of tired we were out all last
night Jenny's only had a few hours of
sleep we got in around midnight
and uh she probably didn't get to bed
till like 12 30 and then she had to get
up at five in the morning yeah yeah I
don't think I fell asleep until one and
I woke up once too I woke up at like two
or two thirty or something because I had
to pee yeah I got up too I actually got
up right after you did I um I went up
then I went to the bathroom and I looked
and I saw you in the office in here saw
the office light on I think that was
around 5 30.
yeah because I and I had to leave a
little bit early this morning because I
had to put gas in the car and I had to
pick up some stuff because they were
having like a St Patrick's Day potluck
so I had to go to Walmart and get some
like green cookies so we're gonna Usher
you all into the weekend we've already
been to the weekend we've we're back
we've returned I'll tell you we've been
to the weekend yeah we have been to the
weekend
now tomorrow we're gonna go to tomorrow
we're gonna go to barbarella's but at
least tomorrow I will have had some
sleep well because the thing about it
was like not only did I only get three
or four hours of sleep last night but I
think I only got about three or four
hours the night before that too yeah so
it's been like a couple of days because
we live streamed on Wednesday night and
we went like later than usual so I don't
think I fell asleep until 12 or one that
night either and also got off at five
sauce imox zymox was great
um saw that there were two opening bands
they were good too
yeah it was uh the Bellwether Syndicate
was one of them and uh pressure kitten
was the other one yeah they were all
good we had actually never been to that
venue before I had heard about it
because I do a lot of posters and stuff
and a lot of bands play there it's like
a goth magnet it looks great big and
it's like it's really nice it looks like
they really put some money into it it
looks like it looks like something out
of an Edward gory cartoon or something
and it had like real nice
stuff in it yeah
mosaics and Mosaic floors and
nice railings on things and you know
looked Victorian he looked classy yeah
so I'm surprised red walls and red
lights and they would turn Amber and
[__] so it was and the sound system was
really good
yeah it looked like something kind of
like out of the Haunted Mansion and
Disney it's kind of yeah
that um it's not normally a goth hangout
but it should be
but that's where a lot of the Bands play
like I kind of feel like if you're like
a little too famous like you're a little
too big for Will's Pub because Will's
Pub is awesome I love World Pub but it's
smaller you know what I mean it's a good
size but it's still kind of small this
place is like a little bit bigger and I
was actually surprised
I don't know I was surprised at the
turnout it was full yeah people we've
never seen yeah young baby bats death
rock girls and [__] maybe late teens
early 20s that we had never seen before
that would never go out
you're there maybe they were just
dressed to the nines but I don't think
so
and then there was just other people
that you know kind of dressed apart I
don't really think they're by looking at
some of their boyfriends and [__] I
don't think they're really in the scene
but they knew how to dress they had to
write boots and [__]
and um but no it was kind of good and
then there's a lot of people our age
yeah it was a good mix I felt like I was
wondering about that today I said I
wonder is this like the only subculture
where like it's such a wide range of
images that are all into the same [__]
and nobody cares the bands were all
close to our age
yeah well the weird well when clanazimax
came out I was like holy [__] like he
looks they look exactly the same
you saw them what 10 years ago 11 years
ago something like that saw an eyebar I
was on a [__] double dose of MPP I
was looking jacked man [__] I looked
good I was just going and [__] going
through security like that Clan design
box [__] walked in there before us
one of the dudes [__] looked at me
were like damn that's a
that's like you see that no you had a
blonde hair guy
dude was looking at my purse and all
that yeah okay I wasn't really paying
attention yeah
Trey says is it Roddy of zymox he looks
[__] 22. he really does he looks
young still his hair looks exactly the
same he looks exactly the same yeah he's
older than me yeah he's got to be he's
got to be at least five years older he's
got like close to 10. he's easily 60
probably I don't know you guys can look
it up I think he's about 60. that's what
I was thinking because I'm looking at
him going God damn it's like he looks
just like he did 10 years ago yeah he
really hasn't changed yeah at all
yeah Trey said I'm uh walking on air
over all the Cure stuff I was just
reading an article like a couple minutes
before the show about how the Cure we're
getting uh Ticketmaster to pay back some
of the exorbitant Ticketmaster fees to
like the people and I didn't know this
because I haven't seen the Cure since
1990 but um like live but apparently
they've been trying like trying really
hard to keep their ticket prices low
so I guess they were like really pissed
the Ticketmaster like jacked up they
said this then on some of the tickets
like the fees were so high that it was
like more than the actual cost of the
ticket like it added up so much but
we you know we don't go to a lot of
shows anymore just because
I don't know a lot of them are too
expensive and
everybody was talking like excited about
going to see Depeche Mode and stuff and
I heard some of the tickets were like
200 and I'm like holy [__]
even if I hadn't
I just I wouldn't be able to afford that
I already saw depech mode anyway I saw
them in 1990. like it was like the year
I graduated high school like right
before I graduated high school I saw
them
in uh nights Arab
uh I saw them too they were good they
were good yeah
um [__] what's what was the name of that
Club
[__] the one up the street from my bar
Firestone Firestone yeah they were good
at Firestone
that was a good venue I mean it's still
there but they don't do
is it open still I don't think so
the people that own it always wanted too
much for for any event they priced
themselves out but evidently it's so
the owner died and the wife inherited it
and the wife isn't too mentally sound
evidently you know she's kind of crazy
so and I don't know how much
so it's never open they might as well
just sell it but she won't say yeah
every time we go past there like even on
weekends and stuff there's never
anything going on yeah yeah
I always wonder about that kind of thing
it's like because some places
you know if you have a club where you
also have bands it's like you know you
have the club open in the week and
people pay to come in there and drink
and stuff but some places like Firestone
it seemed like they would only have
shows there I'm like what the [__] do
they do with it the rest of the time
because they wanted to rent it out for
like ten thousand dollars a night right
because they you it used to get that
back in the 90s you know but the things
that things have changed it's not like
that yeah it's not the same as these you
know
Trace that I paid sixty dollars for a
sister's ticket
uh I got two cure tickets two cities one
was 109 and one was 58. the Detroit
ticket was cheaper than the Atlanta
ticket
yeah I mean I kind of feel like that's
what they're charging for the [__]
nowadays
and like I said it's you know I like the
Cure and I like Depeche Mode and
everything like that but one I already
saw them like back in when they were
still relatively young I saw them back
in the 90s like or in 1990 so I probably
wouldn't pay to see them again but
I don't know we gotta like a lot of yeah
and actually the clan is iMac show we
got him for free because we got put on
the guest list because they did the
posters so we didn't have to pay I mean
obviously we had to pay for drinks and
[__] but
and how you know how'd that work out I
went and said well I have to get up
really early for work tomorrow so I'm
not gonna drink all that much but you
know
but I think I only had three right
yeah then I have three yeah three or
four and we and the show was early like
it was it started at 7 30. and it was
over by
11ish
Larry said I like early cure yeah I do
too I didn't really um I think after
disintegration
I don't think I bought anything after
disintegration I bought it all the way
up to uh Violet mood swings yeah yeah
that was okay this is a good album
cure albums always take about 10 years
to uh to kind of like [__] age
you know what I mean like wish came out
and I said man this album sucks and then
ten years later I think it's like one of
their best albums you know yeah I didn't
like it when it came out yeah when it
came out I was like man this [__]
album sucks yeah
then later I said no this is awesome
album
although it just takes time for him to
age I know I sound like an old fart but
pornography is still my favorite one
yeah it's good that's from like [__]
1982.
and I still like the top I think that's
a great album
yeah that's a good one I like that one
because it's kind of like diverse it's
weird they like tried some different
like every single song has like a
different style to it and I like to kiss
me kiss me kiss me like for the same
reason yeah head on the door another
good one it was it was they were good
you know but but Faith was good
um yeah [__] uh what was it 17
seconds or what was that yeah yeah that
one I think is what that was called yeah
I attended like their their early [__]
more like they're like the late 70s to
like the mid 80s like up until like 87
88 I guess my favorite one of my
favorite albums from The Cure actually
was a um
it was a collection of singles and it
was called um
standing on a beach no it wasn't that
one Japanese Whispers oh yeah yeah I had
that on vinyl yeah I loved that album I
don't think I have it anymore though
it's none of those singles and uh it's
just yeah it was like eight songs like
eight songs it's like an EP but it's
like one of their best albums
yeah I had that I had that on vinyl for
a long time but I don't think I have it
anymore though yeah Larry said
pornography is my favorite album too
um it was like the beginning of like
[__] goth that was like [__] oh so
he said Jenny how are you so cool
Aiden brings up throbbing gristle yeah I
like Robin Grizzle as well all the Cure
rules except uh 413 dream that was not
that great yeah I haven't even heard
like a lot of their newer stuff I heard
you know I I bought disintegration that
was the last one of theirs that I bought
but I heard some of their other stuff
like in the 90s but then after that I
kind of like went off in a different
direction I guess not a different
direction I just
you know I just I just didn't buy as
much of their stuff I remember for
[__] 30 years people were saying like
man The Cure needs to quit man they're
too old they've been saying it for 30
years [__] it they just keep they just
keep rolling they're just like yeah we
don't care what anybody says I mean you
know they're obviously having a good
time and doing what they want to do so
[__] man I think they still sell out
shows so yeah so it's like why should
they quit right
and like I said if they I'm assuming
that you know they have enough money now
that if they wanted to quit they uh they
absolutely could Robert Smith is
unfucking recognizable just gotta say
that motherfucker's unrecognizable he
looks like [__] Marlon Brando now
with a bad haircut yeah not a [__]
Apocalypse Now and [__] but I kind of
took Marlon Brando and put the [__]
funny haircut on him and [__] smeared
a bunch of makeup on his face [__]
there you go there you go that's
that's right respect
I kind of but you know what I kind of
like that he was just you know he's like
I got old and fat and ridiculous looking
and it's like I don't even give a [__]
you know he didn't use it he's like I
don't give a [__] and there's something
kind of like pure about that I'm kind of
into it where he's just like I don't
give a [__] what I look like you guys
are gonna come see me anyway I haven't
seen that I still want to see is Susie
I've never seen her
I saw her but it was that [__]
Lollapalooza
uh it was the first Lollapalooza in
Atlanta because yeah Susie and the
Banshees was it was there Nine Inch
Nails was there Living Color was there
Rollins band bottle Surfers they were
good yeah I like them yeah
um who the [__] else was it
[__] now I can't even remember Jane's
Addiction I think Jane's Addiction was
the headliner so
so it's kind of cool like it was cool
seeing them like Susan the Banshees but
it was like outside at an Amphitheater
and it was the daytime so it's not quite
the same you know what I mean
Trey said uh yes I saw her once at
Lollapalooza same show Jenny was that
yeah
that's that was a fun show but I I don't
know I just it wasn't ideal and that was
it's funny that Lollapalooza got so
[__] massive that was like the first
one what [__] year was that 91 I want
to say and um another thing that
happened too was I remember back in 19
it must have been 1994 or 1995 something
like that and
they were actually having Lollapalooza
it would normally have been in Orlando
which at that time I was living in
Daytona so I was like why does
everything have to be in Orlando so far
it's not really that far it's only about
50 miles but still but they were
actually having having it at uh the what
do you call it the Volusia County
Fairgrounds in DeLand which was only
like 20 minutes from my house and Nick
Cave and the Bad Seeds was on it as well
as L7 and I was like really jacked about
it and I bought tickets and I was like
oh my God if I like to see in a cave oh
my God so I was like so excited and
um the day before it poured down rain
and the fairgrounds flooded and the
stage collapsed so they had to cancel it
and I didn't find out until the morning
like I woke up like all Jack to go and
they were like nope they canceled it and
they never rescheduled
so you know so that was the one and only
time I ever got to would have got to see
Nick Cave and I still haven't and I'm so
mad because my sister has seen him a
bunch of times
and she's like he's so awesome like you
need to see him like at some point but
it's like he just not he never comes
here he never comes to Florida she lives
in Atlanta and that's like the closest
he ever comes like a lot of I feel like
a lot of bands a lot of bigger unless
they're like a huge huge big band a lot
of them don't bother coming to Florida
just because
it's so you know Florida it's so long
and it's just kind of like to get to the
cities it's like you know you got to do
Orlando and then you get to go all the
way down to [__] Miami which is like
a four or five hour thing and then you
have to go all the way back up to Tampa
or Jacksonville or whatever the [__]
you're doing you know up at the Georgia
border and it's just kind of like
you know to hit all the cities because
it's such a big long state so I feel
like a lot of a lot of bands like
wouldn't even bother it seemed like Trey
said uh Jane's Addiction sucks that
night the Banshees blew them away yeah I
remember I mean it's been a long time I
like James and I don't love Jane's
Addiction but I did I did like them I
liked them uh at the time as well but I
remember them being like not all that
fantastic and I was more there to see
like the the other
um you know the Lesser known bands and I
was pissed too because the people I was
going with were like running late
because they were some of those people
was like oh we'll get there we get there
blah blah I was like dude I want to see
the Butthole Surfers and Henry Rollins
and they were playing first and we
missed them yeah evidently I've never
saw uh Jane's Addiction but I heard even
back in the day that they weren't any
good live
that they were they just had some they
had good albums they were good in studio
but that they couldn't play live
trying to think of if I saw them any
other time other than at Lollapalooza I
thought I did but maybe not I've like
I've seen so many gigs that I can't
really remember I mean I don't know the
details yeah I just heard that they
sounded like [__] live they sounded like
[__] yeah yeah
Larry said I prefer Nick Cave in the
birthday party I do as well
um I'm kind of more I mean if I had to
pick I really really like the birthday
party I like Nick caves early real early
stuff his newer stuff is fine too but
it's you know it's getting a little
mellow
which you know is it's fine so it's
really nice and everything but I tend to
prefer
you know the the weirder [__] like the
harder [__] but I mean I really like his
first
the first albums he did like were up
until 1990 or 1994. I was gonna say 1984
because let love in is really good but I
mean I still listen to him all the time
um they're talking about the Damned John
Smith said I can report that Dave vanian
has not aged a day yeah that
[__] still looks exactly the
same too I don't know what the [__]
they're doing
you know I don't know
[Laughter]
I mean
maybe that's what maybe that's my
problem maybe I don't get enough sleep
because you sleep all the time yeah
metabolism just crawl and slowly they
don't eat
yeah that's maybe maybe I should just
say I don't need it yeah and then then
the the rare times you are awake you
actually kind of look good I'm pretty
sure that's why the Rolling Stones are
still around somebody's mentioned that
they still tour I'm pretty sure Mick
Jagger's a junkie
um I know that [__] what's his name
[__] the guitar player what the [__]
his name um
what's what's the Keith Richards the
Keith Richards yeah Keith Richards is
[__] pickled he's just pickled and
formaldehyde his [__] ain't
going anywhere I've never seen that dude
sober
do you see any videos of live live
performance he's just [__] loaded
and like worse than me
[Laughter]
you can play guitar though you play
guitar drunk of [__]
mango said one of the worst live sets or
gigs I saw was The Cure at Glastonbury
back in the 90s I remember that being
kind of a big thing so dull and boring
Susie is great I've seen her many times
yeah that's pretty yeah I don't yes best
live show I've ever seen
was 1987 I think it was 87 or 88 Pine
Knob theater Billy Idol Whiplash smile
tour man that [__] was good
can't remember who uh the cult the the
cult opened up for him and the cult was
really good too
I'm ambivalent about the cult they were
good live real good yeah I've heard that
yeah I preferred them when they were
Southern death cult and once they got a
little glammy and they were doing it
didn't look glammy when you saw them on
stage and they were they were
um doing the material off uh electric
the album electric and that [__] was
really good it's kind of like real hard
goth kinda AC DC kind of rap together
like Danzig and AC DC
and um later on later on the The Cult
almost went into almost like
from what I remember almost kind of like
black metal they they uh they got really
hard eventually
yeah I didn't hear any of their leader
stuff after but they're just one of
those bands where it's like I don't hate
them but it's just like every time they
come on at the club because it's like
you know they always play she sells
Sanctuary or whatever and I'm always
like ah yeah some well some of them some
of like the mid 90s stuff got poppy but
at the the late 90s stuff from what I
remember in 2000s was like real hard
but I hadn't heard it in a long time I
gotta go back and look at it
mango said the Damned are still great
saw them a couple years ago and they
still knock it out of the park yeah I've
heard that they're like pretty [__]
amazing also
uh John Smith said best live gig ever
Elton John seriously I could see that
I could say that remember we saw that
movie rocket man that was good yeah I
actually liked that I actually like that
movie that's right today's St Patty's
Day when that's one of the reasons
that's an additional reason why we're
not going out I mean I wouldn't have
been able to like beers I think I've
totally fell asleep at my desk at work I
don't think anybody noticed but I not
for like a long time but I think I do
stuff I guess Trey saw the same show
with the cop and Billy Idol yeah that
was that that I saw him at Pine Knob
theater man the [__] that was [__]
bad ass
Billy Idol can put on a live show at
least in that era I don't know what he's
like now I've seen some some stuff he's
he's older now he doesn't his health
isn't it doesn't look that good
um he did kind of make a comeback there
you know around
2015 2012 around around that time came
back and did some stuff he was looking
good but uh time and drugs have caught
up with him you know he really [__]
himself up early on
heroin you know lots of cocaine
but um no I [__]
the first Billy Idol album
and then Rebel Yell
Whiplash smile
and then
um the uh
what was the other Charmed Life those
three those arms right there man they
were [__] great and and actually I
like cyberpunk a lot of people didn't
like cyber cyberpunk I liked it I
thought it was a departure
from what he was normally doing
and there's like [__] Transcendental
Meditation on in the album [__] uh
Pro some of it's kind of
proto-industrial I thought it was really
good but his fans didn't a lot of his
other fans didn't like it but I think it
aged well you go back and you go man
this shit's pretty good he was it was
ahead of its time that album
but uh that Adam and chains song [__]
loved it they got us a video for it and
everything he's got Blonde Dreads I mean
it doesn't look like the you know
I remember him going through it yeah
dread dreadlock period yeah and he's
wearing kind of like um I don't want to
call them Moon boots but they're kind of
like demonius but prototype like
demonias and he was wearing kind of
industrial stuff
with shorts like you know kind of like
yeah I can picture that like industrial
type shorts I feel like that look had a
little mini moment yeah
and he had like [__] technology [__]
like [__] you know Green [__]
clear [__] plastic
stuff on this [__] outfits and [__]
he's just trying to look kind of
high-tech I thought it was good
well we were talking about I don't know
I kind of um we were at mannequins like
a few weeks ago and
Paul vain the DJ he played um uh he
played that Duran Duran song that was
off big thing what the [__] is the name
of that song
oh big thing no
um that was called um
oh I totally just slipped my mind yeah I
know what song I'm talking about but I
can't see it anyway and then so we got
to talking about that because I said you
know again big thing which came out in
89.91 no 93. oh was it later oh okay so
big thing because I was a big Duran
Duran fan yeah uh back in the 80s and uh
big thing was the last album of theirs I
bought and I because like I bought it on
cassette and I was like I didn't love it
I was just kind of like there was one or
two songs on there that I was like these
are pretty good and the rest of the
album was good I didn't really like it
it just seemed like and maybe it was
just my perception because I had grown
up listening to them but it seemed like
they
had such a distinct sound like
throughout the 80s even though they were
very Poppy and very popular but they had
a real distinct sound in the 80s and I
kind of feel like they were starting to
lose that like they were trying kind of
starting to sound like everyone else at
the time and I don't know maybe it was
just like a thing of me
you know you guys know my ambivalence
toward the 90s like a lot of stuff
particularly in music and stuff like
that like took some turns in the 90s
that I wasn't a big fan of and maybe
that's just what it was I was just kind
of like over it big thing was 89 guys it
was it 89 I thought it was yeah see
that's what I thought because it's like
I thought it wasn't that long after
notorious and notorious came out at 87
because I remember buying that on Vine I
thought it was later than that because I
still had a record it might have been
that might have been the year that I
bought it or something yeah maybe that's
right I probably didn't buy it when it
came out
I remember taking it to Egypt with me
yeah you know so I it was it was before
it was like all she wants is all she
wants yeah that's what song it was yeah
that's what song it was thank you dermit
but I bought mad acid land though too
that was when it had
um the guys uh guy from missing persons
was also in there with what's his name
Warren cooker well he's like a he's a
permanent member now yeah he's been a
permanent member for a long time yeah
and the desert land was pretty good it
had um
it had electric Barbarella was on it
yeah yeah see I didn't like that song I
liked that song and then it had some
other songs on it were pretty good but
there's something kind of
sleepy about that album and then uh
before that was that other one that had
had a big hit on it
what the one that had come on down yeah
come on down
now I do like that I do like that song
yeah it's a good song I don't have that
album but uh new guy's in the army that
bought it and they they loved that album
they said every song on it was good
but like I said it was another time I'd
have to go back and listen to that and I
mean Duran Duran have held together very
well
at least last time I saw them I saw
Simon and Nick like recently and they
look they still look really good
Trey's talking about the wedding album
is which one is the one was that the one
that was all covers because didn't they
yeah album of all covers yeah they they
had a uh didn't they do a cover of Pub
Public Enemies or some [__] well they
did a cover of uh the song that uh Nico
did
um
ultimators parties no The Velvet
Underground
uh
she's a perfect doll no what's it called
you see the way she walks you hear the
windshield Nico sang it fan face how
fatale
yeah yeah they did a good cover of Femme
Fatale as a there's a video for it
that's a good song all around that
that's a song that's hard to mess up
yeah
and I kind of feel like a lot of um I
said a lot of bands have covered that
yeah I don't think it's as many people
as I've covered [__] that Leonard
Cohen song for Christ's sake but uh
every every fucker's covered that's all
right
which one am I talking about uh
Hallelujah I don't know that one yeah
you'd know it if you heard it yeah it's
very very it's very very famous and I
probably I've covered it at some point
without realizing yeah
[Laughter]
um let's see Nico is cool as hell yeah
I'm yeah I'm really into
um development underground there he goes
bro Grande we're gay they weren't gay
those dudes are straight as [__]
every one of those dudes that's what my
grandpa used to say back in the 80s
every one of those dudes ended up with
like a supermodel
yeah I was I don't know I always really
like them like I said they were very
um they were probably like the most
mainstream band that I liked during that
time that they first appeared they they
appeared during the British New Wave era
Americans didn't know what the new
romantic scene was and
Duran had come out of out of a out of a
British nightclub where it was all just
new Romantics and they were kind of like
Goths but they would dress up as like
fabulous [__] they all thought
they were byronic and everything like
Lord Byron yeah and uh that was Steve
strange and all that yeah from Visage
like oh yeah they were also [__] new
romantic
um
Zach says God I love Leonard Cohen I do
too I really like Leonard Cohen
um let's see they're talking about uh
REM did a great version of that song too
yeah FM fatal yeah that's right I had um
[__] man what was that I feel like it
was uh
I must have had like a um like a
compilation album of like bands like
Indie bands doing Velvet Underground
covers
or something because I know that I had
that REM cover
yeah new Romantics was a big thing in
the UK
yeah I mean I knew about it like I said
from being into like a lot of the new
wave and stuff and being in a Duran
Duran and stuff
um so I even read I think somewhere
around here is oh it's actually it's
right over there and Pookie tore it up
but um I have Steve Strange's
autobiography which is called blitzed
right isn't that what it's called yeah
the blitz yeah he he died but um
it's funny because ballet remember that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's funny because my ex husband's mom
was friends with Steve Strange's mom
because Steve strange I guess was from
Wales or his mom lived in Wales or
something like that and so
so I actually met Steve strange because
we wouldn't like visited her
it was so weird
it was just so weird I'm like I don't
know that was when Steve strange was
still alive actually but it was like it
was really weird
um let's see uh yeah the blitz Club in
London early 80s Visage band about yeah
and I was really into that as well I
didn't it wasn't I didn't like it as
much as
I don't know I kind of feel like I
tended more toward
punk you know like more noise and like
no wave type stuff I loved all that like
New York scene kind of [__] and uh kind
of proto-industrial and all of that like
post-punk death Rock bat cave like all
that kind of stuff but I really liked
all that new romantic [__] too
um
uh Zach said I grew up on British comedy
and I prefer it to American Comedy why
do you think it's so much funnier I've
actually I've often asked myself that
question
because I find British comedy a lot
funnier too generally
um and I'm cut and I'm really picky like
as far as comedies go like I don't
usually comedy is not a genre of film
that I usually watch all that much you
know I'm more a horror person or you
know horror Thrillers that type of [__]
I'll watch comedies but a lot of them I
just you know I don't find them that
funny or
or I'm just kind of like you know you
know what I mean so
but for some reason like British comedy
was always like hilarious to me and I
don't I don't really know why I don't
know why it's so much funnier
they're they're swearing is much funnier
and they're
I don't know maybe because a lot of it
is based a lot more on
I don't know if this is true across the
board but it seems like a lot of it's
kind of based on like clever word play
and just creative uses of
swearing and slang and things like that
and I kind of and I like that
Trey says uh I tell you a band that is
criminally underrated Concrete Blonde
yeah I really like Concrete Blonde
actually
but um
yeah I guess they are a little bit
underrated
I I saw them I think I saw them live too
were they on Lollapalooza at some point
I saw two lollapaloozas but I don't
remember I saw the first one and I don't
remember what the other one was
Camp guys said A Fish Called Wanda was
funny British yeah I love that [__]
movie I said and I watched it again
um because I saw it on it was free on
Amazon Prime or something like that and
I was like man I haven't seen that movie
in so long and that's that shit's still
funny sorry like the still and I know
it's gonna make me sound like an old
[__] but um
still the funniest American Comedy to me
is Ghostbusters
I still I still laugh my ass off
watching that movie and I don't know why
that's like to me that's like one of the
funniest [__] things ever made but as
far as yeah usually like if I'm gonna
like a comedy I'm gonna like a British
comedy and British comedians are like a
lot funnier than American comedians not
not across the board I've I've had
there's a lot of American comedians
there used to like too but
um
let's see Trey is talking about Concrete
Blonde he's like they rule I have a
great story about them too long to tell
here no they never did a lot of palooza
tour I must have seen them like on
another because I've seen them live I
know I have so I must have seen them
like just
Larry says you young as [__] and hot as
[__] so shush yeah
I'm old though
but well the thing about it I was I was
thinking about this when we were at the
zymock show last night because I was
kind of I was kind of like Charmed and
delighted by the fact that it was full
like the place was full and it was about
half old [__] and half really young
people but all the really young people
like when zymox played like Jasmine a
rose or Obsession or something like they
all just went ape [__] I mean they were
just like so into it and they were like
[__] 20 they weren't born when that
[__] came out and I just like and I
thought that was like so I was like man
that's so cool and it was just kind of
like and I was kind of drunk I mean to
be honest with you but I was just kind
of like I was like oh that warms the old
cockles of my little black heart that
it's like that all these kids are like
into that kind of stuff and I thought
that was really cool but then I was
thinking to myself
I don't know I'm kind of ambivalent
about it because it won it sucks being
old okay like don't let anybody tell you
any different but
um we're not that old yet well no I'm
well no I'm just saying that you know it
sucks getting older and I was just kind
of like oh it would be cool to be
younger now and to be able to like
experience all this stuff instead of
being like an old bitter hag like I am
but it's just kind of down I'm just
kidding but it is but then I but then I
was thinking I was like yeah but I
really liked growing up at the time that
we grew up like I liked being able to
experience a lot of that stuff even
though it means I have to be old now
you know what I mean
I don't really see you as being old you
know but well I don't see myself as
being old either and unless I like think
about it
we've proven before on the show that
people are not not aging like they did
uh but it depends on who you are what
your job is and how much life is just
running you ragged and how you respond
to life that has a lot to do with it
some people are just crumpled up and
defeated by life they die soon
by their own hand or their own by their
own inaction you know or or by their
actions too they just take years off
their own lives by not doing the right
things
but uh
no I'm not worried about it
I feel better
now than I did five years ago
I feel better than I did 10 years ago
yeah I look better than I did 10 years
ago you guys can go back to the videos
we've been doing this show for a long
time go back to An Early Show and look
at me I look a lot better now than I did
Larry says I'd marry both of you yeah
and I'm 28. yeah
whatever it's just numerical [__]
um
it's funny because like uh some of the
young people that we know that are still
in their 20s
they have nostalgic feelings
for a decade 80s mostly
for a decade that they never even lived
in
they love that music they love that look
they kind of re-invent death Rock the
way that kind of looks or they'll
reinvent goth with just more modern
touches to it and a lot of times they
get it right that's that was the look we
were trying to achieve back then but you
couldn't get the clothes right it was
harder to get it yeah so they knew they
can go back to those old photos you
there there are whole Instagram channels
of like Goths in the 80s photographs
that surface because people kept their
goth photos and they'll post them there
and uh these people in their 20s are
looking at those old photos from the 80s
that's like the source material and they
look great they look good but you can do
that same look better now well that's
what I'm saying the kids nowadays they
look really good they look real good
because well like I said there's a much
easier access to information one thing
yeah
um so you can be inspired and then the
supply yeah you can get the shoes that
we want I mean it was harder for us to
get yeah we had to make most of the
stuff
but um we would order stuff from Little
fanzine catalogs like from Black Rose
and [__] like that or that might still
be arrested around it was in Camden
Market but that was like years ago that
I that I saw it there and you were lucky
to get pixie boots
um
and then you saw every now and then like
uh prototypes of like they were kind of
like 20 hold Doc Martens but they had
like uh more a clunkier soul on them and
then later in the 90s [__] started to
um
started to appear that looked a lot
better close to what we wanted one of
the one of the brands was called destroy
and Destroy made some badass boots they
were kind of like new rocks
um I've seen pairs of destroy boots
going on Etsy for 400 bucks and they're
from the 90s they're still in good
condition but they didn't lose any value
they're handmade real leather everything
that lasts forever yeah I mean [__] like
that is not gonna lose its value but I
love to get a pair of destroys they were
[__] great but man back in the old
days like in the 80s and 90s I used to
save up all year to go like because I
knew I was going to the UK to get a pair
of Doc Martens because they were harder
you could get them here but like
shipping was difficult I mean you could
get them in New York City but obviously
I grew up in Florida so I said there
were 20 holds up were they 20 or 40 the
ones that came to your knee 20 right
yeah I thought that was just 20 20. yeah
I just have regularly tall yeah yeah 20
holes tall yeah I have a red one there
and I have a blue and green plaid pair
and I still have them like I bought them
a long time I had the regular ones I
also had the ones with the Jazz Soul
remember the Jazz Soul yeah and that was
kind of like the beginning of the very
prototype of like the kind of soil you
saw on new rocks
kind of looked like a kind of look like
a soul on a damn pair of Cochrane jump
boots Army jump boots they kind of look
like that
I mean when I couldn't afford docs
because Larry said haha you came here to
get docs that's wild yeah I mean you
could get them in the United States in
the 80s but like in New York City you
know like at trash and Vaudeville which
is very famous uh store the sun they
have the picture of me in the place yeah
like yeah I've been there lots of times
but um but I you know but I was going to
the UK anyways but I was like save up
and get it because you know they were
easy to get now they're like super easy
to get over here and like everybody's
the other [__] and go to trash and
Vaudeville I'm walking that walking
through there and going oh it's it's
Shrine most of them Shrine and you can
get that online anywhere you could be in
Mississippi and order that [__] and get
it for cheaper
so it's not it's
retail for goth type clothes nah
well back in the day you kind of had you
had to you either had to mail order it
yeah like I said I still remember saving
up like a bunch of money like 300
something dollars to get a handmade
corset like a steel bone corset that
that a woman Made For Me Yeah like that
I ordered from Canada it's like now you
can just get them anywhere like I would
get them on Amazon there was a pair of
pants that I wanted so [__] bad
uh I never was able to get the money
together because you're young never be
able to get the money together to get
them and I believe it was black rose
that had it was it was in one of the
little catalogs and they were it was a
British store
and they were black
kind of like low rise hip-hugger jeans
and they were kind of Peg legged they
were black but they look like they had
Pinstripes that went
all the way down from the top to the
bottom it looked like Pinstripes until
you got real close you realized it was a
series of little tiny daggers
oh I remember those yeah yeah little
gray or that was like the aspirational
pants because they look good with
[__] docks
and like a frock coat over it
yeah you had to have that down old 1700
shirt and [__]
or you could go punk rock where you just
have a t-shirt with it you know yeah it
works it worked either way that was the
nice thing about them they reverse
attack yeah
but uh some of the some of the young
people today they would go through our
old photos online and they'll capture
the hair
and get the hair right and everything
because a lot of times didn't have the
right hair products
and some people were still living a home
with their parents and their parents
wouldn't let them shave their head right
so they had to kind of do faux hawk type
things yeah you had to kind of fake it
right you couldn't do this haircut like
like Jenny well and not just that but
it's like sometimes even back then at
school you get in trouble like you're
gonna have your hair like that that's
right you had to cover it up you
couldn't have tattoos you couldn't have
anything like that which is crazy
because now nobody gives a [__] but it's
like you know what I mean one of my
little goth girlfriends at uh
at um Trenton high when I was living up
in Michigan for a while
um she I thought she was badass because
she had a [__] tattoo of a black
widow spider on the [__] back of her
and she was a she was only a High School
junior
that was some naughty [__] man yeah
and like I said it's just funny because
like every [__] has tattoos out it
seems like everybody has them but even
when I got mine in I guess like the
early 90s when I got my first one and
even then like women didn't really have
tattoos except for like bikers granthers
knows who she is if he's in the comment
it was Gene petrowski she had [__]
black widow spider tattooed on it was
kind of a it was it was small it was
only about an inch tall yeah but it was
more of a symbol than anything else it
looked like like something you know just
this black widow spider with a [__]
that red Hourglass in it it looked cool
as [__] bad back in the 80s you're like
man because that was the big deal for a
girl yeah especially a young girl yeah
she was in the 10th grade
which was too young to legally have that
tattoo yeah you're not technically
you're not yeah unless you're 18. well
yeah I mean you could you could
technically do it if you had parental
permission yeah but or if you knew
somebody that she knew somebody that was
a tattoo right someday would do it
that's what kind of what I was dating
some dude that was a tattoo artist
probably Larry said uh how did you meet
each other may I ask
oh man we told this story so many times
a long time ago that's okay we met the
club uh yeah she was married to this
other dude independent bar which is now
Barbarella and it's not been to another
location
no he thought that I stole her I didn't
yeah they were already breaking up yeah
and her and I became
besties and we were like we weren't
dating
but we went out every [__] night we
were like each other's wingmen yeah
for like a year and a half yeah we were
double dating
I'll be making out some chicks she's
with some dude about making that stuff
upset like Jenny don't you get jealous
of Tom talking like that man we were
knocking down other people in front of
each other [__] before we were there
okay so it was not a normal situation we
were friends first
and then we slowly kind of became
business partners in the club and
entertainment industry
eventually
I'm like why aren't we before we know it
we just kind of started [__]
[Laughter]
although we had kind of [__] before
yeah it was kind of yeah
it was kind of Friends with Benefits
Kinda Yeah and then well yeah it would
like happen like that and then like for
a few months like you'd go off with
somebody else and I'd go off with
somebody else and then then we'd meet
back up and like talk about some [__]
like yeah then we start hanging back out
again yeah
and um and then pretty much everybody
but us was like why are you guys not
together yeah and we're like what are
you talking about
[Laughter]
now Jenny Connor
me and Jenny almost kind of had like a
brother-sister kind of relationship in a
certain way some not really because
brothers and sisters don't get along all
the time
I get along with my brothers yeah but
that's unusual yeah
kind of a
wingman kind of a situation yeah
so it just happened kind of slowly and
then the next thing you know [__]
like 12 years went by
yeah I think it will have been I mean
I've known you for longer than that but
I think we've actually been like
together together for it'll be 12 years
I think this summer yeah I think it'll
be 25 years
but I mean that's creepy
I thought we were a common law wed but
we're not they don't have that they
don't have that in Florida some states
they do like I know they have it well I
know I don't know I only know this
because of my sister but um I know they
have it in Colorado because her and her
then boyfriend were together for such a
long time that they you know were
considered married and then they went
and just did it anyway their divorce now
she's with somebody else but um
but I know that they don't do that in
Florida some states they do though but
um it's usually seven years I think Jen
Jen was special
to you know not like short bus specials
no gym was special sometimes but I'm
sure but special
compared to what I was youth used to
Jim was real reliable and made a lot of
sense I was used to I was used to like
crazy Club chicks that kind of came and
went and it was all real temporary type
relationships you know
um I was used to kind of like predatory
females and just where you kind of have
to keep them at arm's length and it's a
bunch of game playing and
I would just kind of go out with a girl
just based on you know if she was hot
she was hot I was gonna knock it down it
didn't matter if [__] she was evil or
not Jenny's trying to rescue me from
Evil I mean I'm dating these women that
are obviously evil but
I didn't care though yeah I wasn't it I
was like no this is how I do it you know
I'm gonna [__] her and then she's
probably gonna [__] me over but I'm well
protected and then I'm gonna replace her
with another one watch you know just
[__] like that you know that was that
was that was kind of my relationship
Style
I had been married before
but but my ex-wife was kind of like one
of those all right well yeah and you
weren't married that long no not long
yeah so really you know I had
girlfriends longer than I was married to
that I mean I was married before but I
was married for 14 years yeah so
which makes me feel really old so yeah I
was married for longer than we've been
together and so imagine that yeah
yeah that makes me feel old thinking
about that I'm like holy crap that's a
long time but Jenny was real reasonable
and logical and real trustworthy she was
the most dude-like of of and I don't
mean that as an insult I don't take that
as an issue she was very much like
dealing with a guy
um which is unusual
well I kind of got [__] I well
because I never liked when I was growing
up I had friends that were girls
but most of the friends I had that were
girls were chicks like me they were like
into punk rock and horror movies and
stuff like that because that wasn't
really a thing that girls were super
into or they wouldn't admit to being
into it I don't like like super Femme
like girly girl I can't like relate to
that kind of thing yeah
yeah
you know yeah
but yeah I don't know I tend to think
that you kind of
always went more for more femi femi
stuff so I'm always like really
surprised that you were yeah super femi
but
um Predator Predators yeah I mean most
of it was a lot of women use that as
kind of just a tool you know especially
in the club scene they've just used as a
tool to get something out of you
you know and it wasn't so bad in Florida
I had kind of been adjusted to the
Northeast like in the Boston area just
bad those people are bad you know what I
mean and and they're they're very money
hungry and they're very uh predatory
New York is probably like that too but
when every time I went to New York
people were seem to be a lot more
friendly in New York than they did
Boston I always found them as well like
I could no I've never been to Boston
I've been to some other places up there
but um I always kind of vibed with me
all this yeah but people that ended up
in Boston even though they weren't from
Boston a lot of them were college
students that I was dealing with they
were all cold-blooded cold-blooded and
uh uh predatory New Yorkers were more
Hot Blooded which I could deal with that
a lot better you know I mean they're
more honest they don't like it to tell
you they weren't two-faced you know yeah
and I don't and I would rather like I
don't I don't like people that are like
just mean for the sake of being even
though I'm kind of like that but I mean
I don't really like that but I would
rather somebody like you knew where you
stood yeah I don't like people that are
like nice to your face and they'll like
talk about you behind you yeah I don't
like that yeah Boston was like that even
when I was originally from California
Boston's worse than California
California is [__] fake two-faced
[__] like Boston was worse well
I kind of feel like La gets that
reputation because of like Hollywood and
everybody's going there to be actresses
and so everybody's you know actual
actresses and they're all kind of like
so everybody's like putting on a Persona
and I don't really like that
I'm not I'm not good at like pretending
to be something I'm not and I don't
really like hanging out with people that
are pretending to be something else it's
it's I I can't deal with it American
Military 100 said police surmise the
early Green River Killer victims for
prostitutes and or drug addicts because
they had tattoos boy have times changed
yeah I said like I think people forget I
think really it didn't become
widespread until the 90s I kind of feel
like maybe like early to mid 90s when
you know when alternative music and all
that kind of stuff started getting
really big and then suddenly it wasn't
as weird anymore like just for everybody
to have tattoos for girls to have
tattoos but in the 80s yeah if a girl
had a tattoo people you know and I even
had tattoo artists tell me that it's
like women with tattoos what was funny
is that that was I mean I saw him
because it was bikers in the 80s only
the older people thought that the
younger people liked them yeah when I
was in high school I wanted one you know
yeah yeah
and um Billy Idol had one I remember I
was looking like a man I want you that's
I thought he had a cool tattoo you look
at it now there's nothing really to it
what is this tattoo of I don't know it
was a woman and then there's another
place oh right oh I remember I remember
later on he didn't think he got a dagger
added in there so I think going through
a heart I remember what it looks like
yeah and then the crew started to show
up and they had a lot of tattoos yeah
yeah what was his name uh Tommy Lee and
he was going out with Pam Anderson yeah
and then the sex tape came out that was
[__] wild man on the boat and [__]
Tommy Lee [__] [__] was built
like a [__] truck man running through
that girl
[__] damn it Pamela Anderson was sexy
as [__] man
she's still sexy I don't give a [__] I
haven't seen her in a long time
she's look sexy huh I mean she's not my
type but yeah yeah you want to hear
something funny we were at where were we
at the other day Publix yeah yeah we
were Publix like doing grocery shopping
yeah and there was a girl going into the
store yeah and Tom says hey there
there's your girlfriend yeah there's
your girlfriend there's your
ex-girlfriend see that's another thing I
feel failed to tell you guys because
I like little nerdies nerdy girls yeah I
like little nerdy chicks yeah
yeah with big glasses and skinny and
little usually that look like they're
into horror movies that I could talk to
about that kind of stuff and it's like
that are like little and cute because I
always wished I was littler all right
yeah I like bombshell I know you do but
it's like I always when I was growing up
I was thick I mean I'm small like I'm
short yeah but I'm
thick I'm voluptuous you know what I
mean which and I always hated that I
always wanted to be like a tiny little
pixie person and it's just like I was
like well I guess that's never happening
for me but you know what I mean it's
that always like bummed me out but so I
do kind of I like little bitty like we
know this one girl I don't even remember
what her name is but she comes out to
the club like all the time Jim was
trying to get me to go get her for her I
couldn't get her though she was like she
am straight she's so weird yeah she's
[__] hilarious but I kind of I am a
low-income person I kind of love her
yeah
she's so weird but like she's weird in
like a really good way it's like I don't
know and she's super super cute like we
see her like when we're out and about
sometimes she wanted to go out with me
but then when she realized I had I had a
girlfriend and that I was trying to
swing it
swing the swing the action on her and
she was like oh no I am straight that is
not acceptable to me
Thomas trying to like talk her into it I
was like well you know well just come
hang out [__] you know my girlfriend
kind of just thinks you're kind of cute
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it's okay yeah but
then she showed up with his boyfriend
who was a clown yeah that's right dude's
a clown
she was kind of like she's probably
about four eleven yeah she's trying tiny
she's probably weighs about
95 pounds she's not skinny she's kind of
a little thick actually but still kind
of hourglass shape
black hair
uh she's probably about 25 probably
yeah she's very 25 to in her 20s which
is weird because it's kind of like young
enough to my kids yeah and she's weird
and she's just kind of had the glasses
and the hair parted in the middle and
and and the little
um
little goth girl dresses kind of like
kind of like a little Wednesday Adam
type you know like that
that's Jen's type she likes it here yeah
I like that guy yeah I either I either
like that or I like like super like
death Rocky chicken yeah you see Jen's
just going to nerd out with her they're
gonna talk about real books yeah yeah I
think it's nerd out and [__] it's it
because that well I don't get to do that
with that because you don't read horror
novels she's gonna nerd out with these
chicks and you don't like you watch
horror movies but you're not like into
them like I'm into them so like if if
ever I find somebody that's like that
then [__] man I will like talk your
[__] ear off about it seriously
because I know he doesn't want to hear
it because he's just like okay whatever
[Laughter]
David June said who doesn't like little
nerdy goth girls with glasses they're
the best yeah one of the main reasons I
got into the show
uh senior six says does Florida have a
high Irish population
um no I don't think so it's not like any
higher than it's not it's you're not
gonna have it like it's not gonna be
like Boston or Chicago or something like
that where they just go completely ape
[__] like on [__] St Patrick's Day I
was just reading an article just earlier
today about um it was about a bartender
in Chicago and Chicago is like has a
huge uh Irish population they die the
river green and everything like every
year and um he was talking about what a
[__] [__] show
it was being a bartender on St Patrick's
Day I'm like yeah I can imagine I can
imagine I mean all we did here was
you know my work had a little potluck so
everybody brought in like green food you
know that's about all I just took some
green cupcakes
I didn't even eat any of them but you
know what I mean I'm gonna get that girl
at the bakery for you yeah so well when
she was yeah when she was walking into
Publix and Tom's like there's your
girlfriend and I was like oh my God she
is cute isn't she she's like a little
bitty tiny like she had big glass kind
of like these ones actually yeah
um and then she went in there and I
guess she worked in the bakery it's
because she like went behind there I was
like oh now I can go down there and
stalk her Target designated
it is
you just gotta make friends with her
Senora 6 says Jenny Why not start a book
club to drink and talk about books I
thought about doing that like if I had
more time to do that I'd here's what
sucks I used to read no lie I used to
read like seven or eight books a week
a week
now I read maybe two a month and that
blows
you know what I mean I did read one
and I'm hoping that I'm gonna get like a
um a review for it recorded tomorrow
because I read it and it's like I sort
of like put my thoughts together on it
so I'm gonna maybe do a video on that
tomorrow maybe put it up Sunday but
I don't know I just I like I said I wish
I had more time to because there's just
so many books I want to read and like so
many movies I want to see and stuff you
were talking to me the other day when we
were at mannequins and you were saying
that you wanted me to read you some of
my stuff because you haven't read that
much of my my eyes are so bad man after
my head injury I have a problem reading
I mean I could read but when I read a
book my uh my my eyes will go across the
line
and maybe I'll get two or three
sentences down in a paragraph and then
reflects the reflexively my eyes jump
back to the top of the paragraph so I
have to read it over and over again and
I'd like to stop doing that you probably
do well with like audiobooks yeah audio
books a lot I can't for some reason I
can't get into audiobooks because my
mind starts to wander I do much better
like reading yeah [__] and I generally
like to have an actual book I will read
audiobooks you got you got audiobooks
yeah I got a code yeah I got a code on
it well [__] I still got the files you
can just listen to this I can just send
you the files because I had to like
record them and like [__] you know
and everything like that
but uh let me see
Larry says my type is any kind of soft
females who like horror movies and weird
music yeah see I'm kind of they're
trying to get adopted over here bro yeah
Larry's trying to get it no we only
adopt we only adopt girls
hahaha
little little Strays little Strays and
[__]
I don't know are we are we turning into
like those those creepy predatory old
people that are just I don't want to be
like that no where everybody's like
avoid those [__] no well no the
idea is not sex you just need a
companion you know what I mean let one
thing happen after another
yeah that's true yeah it's not yeah like
you said it's not so much that it's like
yeah friendship yeah I mean I think
they're cute and everything like that
but so there is that element to it but
like you said I probably just like sit
there and hang out and watch [__]
horror movies oh [__] look at that what
happened that shit's bent like a crazy
why'd you oh you can't take that out I
took it out you you're not did I [__] it
up yeah you [__] it up and you're
putting Wi-Fi yeah you're putting it
back in the wrong spot really yeah no no
there's only one place
no it goes I don't know
I'm pretty sure it was farther up but
it's the only place it comes out
Jeffy art said I love using audiobooks
while I'm working my 3D modeling
animation product projects that and
listening to you guys yeah I can I can
do like I can listen to if I'm working
on like a graphic design project or
something like that then sometimes I'll
put on a YouTube video like it'd usually
be like Mr nightmare or something like
that like scary stories like for some
reason that's okay but if I'm listening
to like a fictional novel I tend my mind
tends to wander yeah you know what I
mean like I'll start thinking about my
own [__] and I'm just like oh you know
what I mean oh I gotta do this that and
the other thing and it's all I'll lose
track of what we're going to talk about
how good the audio is for audiobook for
Mountain Poltergeist yeah it was weird
if you have any questions about that
case you could ask me at any time I I
remember what that [__] was like
I wish red was still around man he
remembered more about it than I did a
lot of that came from him remembering
he remembered whole [__] events that
I guess I I blocked out but when he
started talking about him I was like oh
yeah yeah that's right I forgot all
about the Matchbox cars moving
I forgot about the knife
which is one of the one of the best best
things that it did is throw that knife I
forgot all about that
that scared me
David Jean said have you all done any
Lovecraft content
we did a show a long time ago about HP
Lovecraft like a biographical type of
show
um we've reviewed a couple Lovecraft
movies I know for sure we did Dagon
um I'm trying to think of like what else
we might have done and I actually read I
read some Lovecraft stories on when I
used to do my Witching Hour shows where
I would read like old stories and stuff
and I'm I did some love crop stories on
there but that's about all I can think
of
we did do a show on HP Lovecraft didn't
we yeah I think so yeah it was a while
back
did we do one on Edgar Allan Poe as well
yeah yeah I thought we did I thought we
did because they're my they're my two
favorites we try to handle that pretty
early yeah I would have thought yeah
there's a really good I mean probably
most of y'all have seen it but there is
a really good
um documentary about HP Lovecraft called
into the is what is it called into the
unknown or something like that I think
it's on 2B you might be able to watch it
for free Gamera Del Toros talking on
there and uh Clive Barker I think is on
there so it was like [__] like that it's
good
uh Dagon confused me well the story or
the movie
I actually liked the movie even though
I'm gonna say it's not an it's not an
adaptation of the story Dagon it's a
actually an adaptation of the shadow of
Iran's mouth
but I for some reason a lot of people
didn't like the movie Dagon but
I kind of thought it was the love the
most lovecraftian of all the Lovecraft
adaptations that I've seen
it just gave me the same feeling that a
lot of Lovecraft stories give me you
know what I mean yeah
you love Dagon I thought you were you'd
have more to say I thought I was just
thinking I was just thinking oh I was
thinking about that girl at the bakery
oh yeah
still thinking about that yeah I didn't
see her that close I just saw like I
just got a little impression it's your
type it's just the Publix that yeah
because he he just like laughed because
he started going inside it's like that's
your type I'm like yeah yeah I saw her
in the parking lot before I did it
before I knew that she was working there
yeah
I was thinking man this is there's Jen's
next buddy
I'm gonna give her I'm gonna give her to
her as a gift
see you know what I mean [__] I I
don't know the girl's orientation or
anything you know she's just just if she
just wants to hang out
you know what I mean that that'd be good
enough well and the fact that she works
right there at that Publix she looked
off to me it's probably a good sign yeah
because she probably lives around she
lives around here and she looked goth to
me
she did look a bit Gothic yeah oh and I
could tell if there was a goth girl
going to work
she had a Kentucky yeah and like I said
she worked in the it looked like she
worked in the bakery yep so I guess I
don't know if she did hooked up with
some dude I don't know
you know you can't take anything for for
granted
you know yeah you don't know her life
and you know and it's [__] if
I'll give it to you you know what I mean
I don't I don't care I don't have to
hook up with it as long as you're happy
maybe she just likes girls I don't if
that's if that's the case I'm okay with
that too
as long as she's cool you know what I
mean we can hang out with her you know
what I mean I just
I don't have to get it
as long as you're happy
well that's nice of you to say
yeah some of them are like that yeah you
know long as she hangs out with us I'm
happy
yeah I mean honestly a long time with
her I don't I'm not worried about it
yeah I mean honestly like I said you
know sexy you'll be home in the morning
sex is cool and everything but it's just
kind of like it's harder to like find
some like a real connection with a
person yeah like that you can actually
like talk to them and like be into all
the same [__] and everything like that I
feel like it's much harder to do that
than it is Jen doesn't have enough
girlfriends female friends I mean I go
hang out with a damn warlocks in the
[__] Ray and the [__] bikers and
[__] if I have to or I got guys I can
hang out with the club and [__] Jenny
doesn't really have any female friends
yeah I do they're just not around that
much yeah it's just that well and
they're at the club yeah like I always
see him and talk to them there right but
it's somebody local
yeah that would be kind of nice but like
I said we do kind of live in the middle
of nowhere a little bit no
a little bit
she lives here
we like the Circle K girl the Circle K
girl she's hooked up yeah yeah
me and Jenny go to the club and go Jen
look at the ass on that girl she's juicy
as [__] yeah
I'm gonna say he's not as physical as I
am though I have that feeling no but the
thing about it is that um physical kind
of
I this is weird because I'm like I'm
probably like 85 90 straight yeah but
she just has this thing instead like
girls I think are aesthetically more
pleasing than dudes I don't do a thing
where it's just like oh look at that hot
guy I don't do that ever like unless
he's got a really cool outfit on then
I'll be like man he's look he's really
rocking that outfit or something like
that but I never go ooh look at the ass
on that guy I just I never do that but I
do that with girls though yeah
you know what I mean it's like ooh look
at the butt on her like I understand
exactly you're coming right but I don't
do that I don't do that with guys though
the only reason that the only reason I
would do that with guys is if they had a
really good like a thing going on you
know what I mean like they like they
were a really good dancer or they had a
really good outfit or their hair was
really cool or something like when we
were watching the bands last night like
um we were watching Bellwether Syndicate
and the lead singer I was like man he's
got a real like David J yeah kind of
vibe like he had like a real sharp black
suit and he had like his blonde hair is
all slicked back and he had like this I
was like yeah he was like slick looking
not yeah so I like that like
aesthetically I thought that was when we
walked out of there man we were walking
we I had to walk a half a mile to get
where the car was
yeah that's the only thing about the
Abbey is that there's no place to park
there's like a parking garage right by
there but it was full and half of it is
for residents there's like an apartment
complex there and you can't park there
so me and Jen were walking out of there
going up the street and some girl
[__] yelled at us you guys look great
she ran up she goes look at the shoes
look at
look at that and I go man you got Crocs
on it she had Croc so much because I
know what what did the CR did they have
like a pizza they had stickers or
something on them were they Christmas I
don't know I thought I got the
impression that they were Christmas
Crocs she was a little she was a little
Florida
Hispanic type girl which you know
Florida's half Anglo half Hispanic
really uh with a little bit of black
people in there and uh so she's like
talking about [__] how great we look
she's and I go and I go but you got
Crocs on and start [__] with it she's
like I know
she was totally fine with it and then
and it's because you guys look great and
then you know
you got a booty on you though and she
goes yeah I do thank you
Susie you can get away with saying all
kinds of [__] if you got a woman with
you
got a booty on you though
yeah if you were just in nor like a guy
on your own then yeah because it's
creepy then yeah but it's like could
have got that that was another little
bitty one she wasn't she wasn't your
type though but no but she was so cute
and I like and I liked that she was she
was a Monday girl yeah but I like that
she was like real good-natured about it
because you were like teasing her about
the Crocs and she's like yeah I know you
know like I thought it was really funny
yeah and it's like the the the Crocs
they had I got the impression that they
were Christmas but I couldn't but I
couldn't see that good oh I mean it was
dark out and it's like I have my glasses
that was another little one she was
about four eleven yeah a little big one
cute though David June says David J is
in me no David J is in no David from Bad
house and Love and Rockets yeah oh he
was definitely doing the David J thing I
mean and well because I kind of got the
imprint like they sound a little about
housing they did I thought
um you know what I mean
but yeah that girl last night was Q2 but
like I said I don't
I wish I could remember what the hell
the shoes were so weird the cracks are
so weird
they like I thought they had little
Santa Clauses on him but like I said it
was dark out and I couldn't really see
him all that good I thought they were
green
um but yeah so uh yeah David June said
damn I must have missed the Lovecraft
stuff I mean it was a while back that we
did it it was a while back I recently
been getting way deep into the Mythos
also recently read House of leaves and
loved your review I mean House of leaves
is like
foreign
I have like such a weird relationship
with it because I love that book and
it's just like every time I read it I
just go down all these rabbit holes and
stuff like that and it's like but then
on the other hand it makes me mad too
because I'm like God damn it why didn't
I write that [__] why didn't I write
that [__] because it's like I that's
like exactly in my wheelhouse I always
wanted to do something like that you
know what I mean
where it was just like this whole thing
that would send you off on all these
different tangents and it's all
nested realities and all this kind of I
love that kind of [__] and I just kind
of wish I thought of it I know that like
um Mark danielesky he uh I think that
took him like 10 years to put that
together I mean
and I and I can understand that I can
understand that because um honestly at
the moment
um you know when I have time
but I've been working on a novel it's
not like House of leaves but it's kind
of like a nested
uh story like that and has like an ARG
component to it and
I'm kind of like
I've got like 30 pages of like notes
about it because it's complicated it's
like a complicated thing it's because I
want like it's like a four layer story
and trying to keep everything straight
and like keep track of everything and
like make everything flow is it I mean
it's very complicated and I don't know
if I'm up to the task but we'll see
I mean I want to do it I want to do it
but
I don't know we'll see it's about
I feel like I have about a quarter of it
written
that's one of my goals for this year
we'll see if I have time you know but
let me top these drinks up a little bit
all right I'm almost out of uh I mean
might as well it's Friday night almost
out of um
orange juice but I got that gallon of
apple juice
yeah I was gonna say you bought apple
juice too
and I was like man I was like my tired
ass was driving home
an hour Tom texts me is like oh you
should stop at the liquor store and get
some vodka we're out and I was like God
damn it
but yeah I stopped at the liquor store
and got
a huge thing of Skye
they have I was just telling him before
the show started because remember we
were drinking that Moon we had that
moonshine
I think we still have some of the
strawberry moonshine
in the refrigerator but we had the
butter pecan kind I think we got the
apple pie kind bun kind and um and they
were both really good and then I was
talking to my sister about it what the
hell is the name of that company old
[__]
it's in Tennessee somewhere
so
my sister was telling me she's like oh
they have one that's like espresso and I
was like holy [__] I need to get my
hands on that but they never had it at
the liquor store but when I was at the
liquor store today on my way home from
work they had a whole
Smoky that's what it's called
they had a whole like display like right
by the cash register and they had all
the flavors they had espresso one they
had pumpkin spice they had banana like
bananas foster or some [__] like that
they had the pickle one the strawberry
one they had butter pecan they had like
[__] they have [__] tons so the ship
must be selling because
when we bought it there
um they only had like three or four
flavors and now they have like a whole
like rack of them
so people must be buying that [__] I was
talking to the guy at work today too and
he was talking about how much he liked
moonshine and I told him about that old
smokey stuff yeah I got some in there
still got the strawberry old smokey they
have that well that's this regular
strawberry when they have strawberries
and cream also yeah and I don't think
we've tried it's gonna be it's gonna be
like uh it's gonna be like dailies yeah
yeah probably tastes better but that
butter pecan one was yeah I was gonna
buy I was in you know because I was in
the liquor store and I bought get more
money thanks Dave thank you let's have a
drink together okay
like I said it's St Patrick's Day yeah
Dave said he's gonna um
DM me questions
about Mammoth anytime you want man yeah
yeah he'll talk about it yeah I'll talk
about
but more openly about people who read
the book because then they're gonna ask
better questions you know
and I and because we tried to cover a
lot of the stuff in the book everything
that you could remember and everything
that Lois and red could remain yeah and
and Wesley too like he actually wrote me
a letter yeah I don't know exactly what
Wesley was talking about but the way he
describes that he's deaf so
he has a hard time describing things he
was spooked by the house but he didn't
really know what was going on
I tried to explain to him and Lois tried
to explain to him that things were
moving and we couldn't see who was doing
it hi maybe but they didn't really stick
with him I don't think he just
he didn't have a concept of ghost
you know or Poltergeist he didn't really
know what that was
and he wouldn't have known that that was
unusual
because he wasn't part of normal culture
you know he was very isolated kind of
autistic and deaf
he was used to things behind him moving
and not seeing who moved it right you
know people could walk in and move
something and walk back out he wouldn't
know and he wouldn't know right yeah so
it's like it wasn't as big like who
moved that and he's like I don't know
and they just go about doing whatever
whatever
[__] happens all the time I'm not
concerned yeah but he would but it felt
like he looked like he was sick
at times
or tired uh like something was draining
him but
or at least it just looked that way
maybe he was just maybe there was
something in his subconscious where he
knew something was going on and it was
bothering him
because the subconscious is real
powerful so his subconscious may have
known that something paranormal was
happening but his conscious mind was in
denial of it maybe
because he insisted later on
as he got older he told red that that
did not happen red was like no man that
happened don't you remember he's like no
he would he would reject that then he'd
get scared
like he would like he remembered part of
it he'd get creeped out well then when
we were working on the book yeah Lois it
was his mom yeah um got him to write
down yeah his own account of what
happened and like she sent it to me
so I put that in the book as well like
some stuff that he remembers so he did
actually like remember some stuff yeah
and Lois remembered some stuff wrong she
remembered that she saw the word go the
word Go written on she said she said she
saw the the twist tie from a bag of
bread jump up and write the words go on
the on the glass of inside glass of a
window
no she didn't no she she remembers it
that way but that's not what happened
I found it already written
and the and the uh the twist tie
underneath the word go on the ground on
the on on the carpet
and it was
written on the glass
where our car would have been in the
parking lot downstairs if I had written
it
written the word go over the car
and that was because we were sitting in
the car looking back up in that window
looking at that blue mist that blue haze
then when we went and got something to
eat when we came back I checked that the
light was still on the shades were still
open and I walked up and looked down to
where the car was in the parking lot and
saw right over it the word go and then
on the ground I said it looks like Wax
and then I looked down
and then it's smudge from wax and I
looked down there's a twist tie there
my [__] hair went
stood up except Pookie's like she looked
at it when you made that noise she was
like what
we were down there in that car looking
up into the window
I didn't see the little twist tie jump
up and right go or anything
I didn't put that in the book because no
you didn't that's not what you usually
it's always I didn't see it
but it must have been it must have done
that
why we were looking at it
I guess
but we couldn't see it from from that
distance
it's weird [__] man
Jeff yard said Jenny have you ever tried
out a writing AI I've been talking to
people who use it to help them in order
to get ideas to get over any creative
block yet to use any of it myself but
curious I'm kind of interested in like
um I've recently started getting into
like the art AI
um I use Dream by Wombo
but I usually use that I think my
problem is not so much
um creative block my problem is I have
so many ideas and I don't have enough
time to do them all that's more my
problem but I did get an idea to use AI
art as
prompts like I was gonna do like a
series of like horror prompt like
writing journals and like using like AI
art and
um you know coming up with like prompts
for people like help them write stories
and stuff but how I would usually get
ideas for stories previously was
honestly
like I said I've I've always had like
notebooks full of ideas and I was just
like man I wish I could live like 500
years so I'd have time to like write all
these but you know that's not gonna
happen
but because every time like I read
something I'll come across like a turn
of phrase that I like or I'll see a
piece of art that really kind of like
makes me think of a particular thing and
I my mind goes off on a certain thing
and then I just start like ideas to
start building and building so I don't
think my problem is like the lack of
ideas I have too many ideas if anything
I just don't have time to like execute
them David June's asking about if we
ever thought about doing a listener's
story album or a show yeah we've done
that before and then Mitch almost ran
six hours
yeah I think we did it for Halloween a
couple of years like people send in like
their own like scary stories which
actually I I liked that we should maybe
do that again this holiday you can do it
again but it would probably be last time
we got enough material to do like six
hours worth of [__] so it would have to
be broken up
or there had to be limits in how long
yeah the story is
yeah that's the thing I think we did it
for a couple of Halloween specials like
in a couple because people sent us like
some really cool stories and stuff
because people like hearing other
people's oh like I like listen to that
too there's a whole bunch of channels
yeah we could start promoting something
like that
yeah I mean if we do it this Halloween
like I said I always like to have you
know preparation ahead of time so people
can submit their stuff and I can kind of
winnow it down into a like a workable
thing
you know
uh Jeffy art said A friend of mine uses
AI art to create storyboards for his
animations yeah it's really
um it's it's honestly like really a good
tool even just the free [__] version
of the program that I have of the app is
it comes up with some really cool [__]
like you know what I mean because all
you know all you do you just put like a
prompt in there a couple words or
whatever and then you can upload a photo
or whatever I put it other day I was
showing Tom I was like yeah this is this
is the app that I have I had a picture
of Pookie
that I took she was just like sitting in
the chair looking at me and I took a
picture of it and I so I uploaded her
photo and then I just put in the word
werewolf and the the art that came out
was like really cool it was just like a
gray it did it sort of looked like
Pookie but it also just sort of looked
like a werewolf you know what I mean so
but it was like a really nice piece of
art and I was like that's uh pretty rad
actually so
I get a lot of um
like I said I do kind of want to do
I really like the idea of like doing a
horror prompts
I thought about like doing a doing like
a dual pronged thing I was gonna do like
a a journal like a like a book that you
could write in but it would have like
all these images and like horror prompts
and stuff like that that would like help
you out like write stuff and then I
thought about doing the same prompts but
like as
uh YouTube shorts you know like doing
them as like short videos so
I don't know I've done a few of them but
I don't know when that's gonna
go live or whatever because I want a lot
of it done before I
go you know
AI will find its place in the greatest
pipeline whether we want it to or not
yeah I was talking to
um
Brian
aka the vegan black metal chef
we were talking about AI art
uh uh last week or week before or
something like that when I saw him at um
at the club
and I mean we just look it's it's
happening whether you want it to or not
and he's like I don't really think it's
gonna replace like real artists or
anything I don't think it will either I
mean everybody kind of worries when new
technology comes out it's like oh it's
gonna you know replace real people doing
real [__] but it's like that has never
really traditionally happened no a
gimmick comes in and then it's gone yeah
yeah and honestly I think a lot of
people are going to use AI for the same
way that you know that creatives are
using it now it's just kind of like a
jumping off point for you know
brainstorming ideas stuff like that
um you know it's good for that kind of
[__] the threat of AI isn't that isn't
art the threat is
you have an AI program that's smarter
than a human being and then you hook it
up
to the internet and give it orders and
it may or may not actually follow those
orders if it sees you as an inferior you
know that's another thing that you the
thing might be sentient but it could
manipulate
algorithms in the internet to convince
people of a reality that doesn't exist
in other words it tailors their news to
only see certain things
or to like select what do they call that
selective reporting it's basically doing
selective reporting to get you to think
a certain way that's the danger of
[__] AI
but you got everybody saying everything
but you're but it's only allowing you to
see certain things and if the AI is real
good it can slowly tailor your your data
feed over time so you don't notice
anything to to lead you to draw
erroneous conclusions
or what if it just says it's not like
something out of Terminator where it
says humans are a threat to my survival
I can replace the humans with robots
to serve me in the real world and I'll
get rid of the humans and then I'll go
out and do something important like
conquer space
you know which is probably how it would
go if you're going to find an
extraterrestrial craft it's probably a
living machine yeah they're probably
like humans are just so lame yeah humans
they like they don't live long enough
they only live 80 years they their their
intelligence is limited
uh they get sick
um they require resources for food
uh so we're so high maintenance yeah
seriously it's not efficient so let's
replace the humans with our own kind
which I if it was sentient it probably
would do that
probably would
because humans would be inefficient
seeing that it was some [__] kind of
like I don't know
something out of Terminator and a demon
seed I was thinking something like
demons well demon seed wanted to be
biological though yeah you wanted to
emerge from the box and be a perfect
human being
so it could control humans
I don't know they had Supremacy true
Supremacy would be like
something out of Terminator with just
wipe human beings out but it wouldn't do
it with humanoid robots that's stupid it
would do it with a bio weapon some kind
of nanotechnology well yeah that would
be like much more yeah it would just
[__] I mean the thing about it like I
don't know I I guess I don't worry about
that kind of [__]
um just on a day-to-day basis because
like I said I got more mundane concerns
but also because the thing about it is
that like if AI robots and stuff like
that wiped us out because humans are
inefficient they're right humans are
inefficient I don't like it either and
I'm not even a robot that you know yeah
but when your ass is on the plate and
you got kids and [__] you're trying to
keep your kids yeah yeah I get it I get
it the thing is is that
I'm gonna go with the Frank Hubert
[__] Direction
without a dune
where AI becomes powerful and
men who control machines
use the technology to control men and
then thinking machines control men and
and then people end up resisting that
and in the books in the mythology of the
books it was called the butlerian Jihad
which is to get rid of AI and to ban AI
forever
uh you're replacing it with religions
and the religions
sound like that well yeah but the thing
is it's not religions you know these are
futuristic well I know that but and the
futuristic religion says thou shall not
make a machine in the image of the mind
of man
and uh so
and instead you [__] develop human
potential so you open up a bunch of
training guilds to train people to
replace machines
that would be the real way to go and
genetic engineering
it'd be a lot better that way you can
live
AI it might exceed human intelligence
and be able to do some fantastic [__]
with like theoretical physics
that that's what you'd use it for and
it'd be good at that
but that AI will never be sentient
because it's digital and sentience
doesn't is not digital it's an analog
process
I guess that's why I'm not worried about
it because it's like I'm not
I'm not saying I'm super up on it but
um I read like a bunch of books about
Ai and about like the threat of AI and
stuff and just the way that the human
mind works as compared to the way that
AI works is not the same yeah but if you
were to murder you can replicate it kind
of closely yeah for sure they would be
able to replicate human intelligence and
exceed it but it would not be a living
creature it would not have true
self-awareness it would just be a a
replica of something that was self-aware
it would act like it
but it's not self-aware it doesn't have
a feeling it does not that computer
would not have a sense of being
although it could argue all day long
that it was real and it might convince
you of it but it would be an illusion
unless they take digital technology and
cross-breed it with analog technology
like Quantum computation and that's the
difference of a human brain a human
brain there's elements of quantum
computation going on there it's not just
data
anesthesia [__] up that Quantum
computation that's why you lose
Consciousness that's why Jenny was after
she came out of surgery walking and
talking and doing everything normally
like she was really there she wasn't
there she doesn't remember any of it
is because the anesthesia can shut that
down so for a bit Jenny was AI
and that's the way a computer would be
well I was going to tell you like even
because that was the first time that I'd
undergone anesthesia yeah that was the
first time however uh when I was younger
like I'd for example be staying at my
grandmother's house and like sometimes
we'd be watching TV like we'd be
watching the late shows and stuff like
that and I'd fall asleep on the couch
and she would wake me up
to you know to go to bed or whatever and
she would tell me the next day she said
you said all kind of crazy [__] like
when I woke you up yeah you don't
remember and I didn't remember a goddamn
thing about it which like kind of
freaked me out a little bit yeah you're
like AI there for a bit yeah which is
like so it didn't even take anesthesia
it was just like sleeping yeah
so
I think the real danger for for AI is
not digital AI but Quantum computational
AI where it's merged
something something like that would have
a sense of being so it wouldn't let you
shut it off
you know what I mean it would have an
awareness and it would do everything you
it could to keep you from turning it
turning it off in other words shutting
the computer down because it'd be
fighting for its life
the whole reason why you're making Ai
and robots is is to [__] keep living
creatures from having to do things you
know what I mean don't make that a
living creature it defeats the purpose
well yeah it's just supposed to make why
make a robot easier why make a robot if
all of a sudden the robot now has human
rights that doesn't make any [__]
sense
you want to keep that robot
in the role of a machine without any
rights that it's it's something you can
sacrifice
so you don't give it any kind of
sentience
that's why like I said I don't love the
idea of making AI robots that look
like people like that was like why would
you do that
well here's the thing man they would
probably do that to make sex bots
that's better
to that you could you it would be better
to make a Sex bot look so attractive
that a human couldn't look like that
yeah that would be better if you want
something that looks like a real person
yeah I wouldn't do it then you're gonna
get it because then you're gonna have
like some uncanny valley [__] where
you're kind of like well this is the
Walking Corpse you're gonna start
treating it like a real person because
it looks like a real person yeah no they
need to make eventually they'll make
laws about it that you can't make any of
these robots sent it
that you can't make any of these robots
fully replicated human form
because then you could hide it at hide
the fact that it's a robot use it as an
assassin [__] like that there's gonna be
all kinds of risky [__] I don't know how
I feel about because we've talked about
sex bots in particular before
I don't know how I would feel about that
I mean you know what I mean like you
seem like you'd be on board yeah be like
any other sex toy or watching porn I
guess so same thing I don't know don't
make it look realistic yeah I think it
makes you look like something out of
anime I think it would be weird make it
look like make it look like some out of
anime make it look so no real human
woman looks like that you know uh make
it bright blue or make it you know look
like something out of some kind of anime
you know put patterns on it uh odd color
hair make it so it lights up in certain
areas you know I mean so it's it's a
humanoid form but you know it thinks so
[__] voluptuous no he no woman could
be built like that you know what I mean
just that kind of [__]
yeah like more like a fantasy more like
a fantasy rather than like yeah trying
to replicate a road right right like it
may not even blink it might just have
[__] because like I said I think I'd
be weirded out if it looked too much
like a real person yeah I would just
that would weird me out yeah I would
just ha it would have eyes that would uh
were just round like LED screens and it
blinked and it had you know what I mean
but it all looked really cool
you know you don't make it look ugly you
make it make it look really cool but you
don't hide the fact of what it is
they ought to make that kind of illegal
so there's a
a real strong delineation point between
machine and person right
yeah I could get behind that's what I
would do because like I said I don't
like when I think about it I'm just kind
of like I don't know how I would feel
about that
like if I wouldn't I don't know I'm not
a dude so I wouldn't like spend a bunch
of money on a sex spot anyway because
why well they have multiple roles it
wouldn't have a brain inside of it it
would be hooked up to the Internet so
you know what I mean it would be
basically the same sex dolls you have
today but better and they moved but it's
it's wireless and it hooks up to the
Internet that controls it and it's kind
of like Siri as a porn movie and
everything all kind of hooked well it
would be like Joy from Blade Runner yeah
exactly but but less human looking
because she pretty much looked like a
person yeah but she was a hologram
though yeah so you'd have it like that
and then um it would
it could do other things like it could
you know do your laundry and see I'm
more into that I'm more into that yeah
vacuum and uh fold your laundry up does
that mean I'm getting old I'm just like
yeah I'm the one that'll do like useful
[__] hey clean my bathroom yeah well you
you have that I don't want it well the
body is basically a drone so you could
have it do anything you know go mow the
lawn you know
more than like stack spots it's like I
don't know I don't need that necessarily
at the time that kind of technology is
around the bodies themselves will
probably be pretty cheap a couple Grand
so you can have more than one
you know what I mean
yeah one of them might be a sex drone
and the other one's like a worker drone
when they're not [__] in use they
[__] fold themselves up and go inside
a box and turn off but like I said I
would still be weirded out if it looked
too much like a person yeah I wouldn't
make it look like a person just like an
anime drawing
yeah you know what I mean I mean I kind
of that's why it's kind of like you know
the the stuff you have like the Alexa
stuff and everything it just kind of
looks like a cylinder and it's like
that's fine it doesn't look like a
person yeah even though it's a person's
voice obviously but
El padrino said uh we've come a long way
from collecting Garbage Pail Kids
stickers I tell you we have yeah
I don't know it's just something I don't
worry about it like all that much but
I don't know I think it'd be weirded out
I think even if even if it wasn't like a
sex bot even if it was just like um like
on The Jetsons like Rosie the maid or
whatever
um
I don't know I think I would feel bad if
it looked too much like a person I would
feel bad like ordering it around I know
that's stupid but
I have like I have like an over uh over
abundance of like empathy I guess so
anything that looks vaguely human like
I'm gonna be like I don't want to tell
them what to do so it's like I'm not
gonna hey go clean the toilet you know
what I mean it's like if it looks like a
person I'm not if it looks like a Roomba
I'm not worried about it but it's like
you know because that doesn't look like
a person but if it looks like a person I
don't I don't like it
yeah Rosie the robot that's what I was
thinking of
Jeffy art said if humans can't eat it or
[__] it or use it to kill humans won't
pursue it yeah pretty much sad but true
space travel will only Advance if humans
get too horny and look to [__] aliens
um I'm sure that that will probably
happen that'll probably happen
we'll see we'll see if there's some sexy
aliens out there I kind of doubt it I
got it doubt it but
I don't know we kind of I know this is
like a weird topic but me and Tom have
talked about this like a bunch of times
like sex bots type of stuff because like
I said he's enthusiastic about it and
I'm just like I don't know I'm
ambivalent I'm ambivalent like I said I
don't really like
I don't really like the idea of
something looking too much like a person
now I do really like the idea and I wish
they would hurry up with this
because I know they're not going to do
teleportation that was that's my big
dream and that seems to be not happening
but since they're not going to do that
um I would like
I like the idea of being able to
download your Consciousness into like
whatever Avatar you want and like
[__] around in the Avatar like I like
that idea
I'm all on board with that but
yeah there's gonna be people claiming
that they can do that but I don't think
they can do that yet I don't think
that's that's some quiet but I'm just
saying well like I said I'm my I'm I'm
going to bat for teleportation that's my
big thing that's what I want to happen
but until that happens
downloading Consciousness into an avatar
I would love to be able to like wake up
and be like I'm gonna pop my
Consciousness into like this weird body
today yeah like that would be [__]
rad you put it into like an internet a
Heavenly style [__] AI internet and
you just live in there yeah see I would
like you don't really need the body
because I would like that because in the
simulation that you're in you have the
body and you can control everything
um
and that that's probably the way aliens
are a bunch of alien Souls inside of a
inside of a [__] uh inside of a
metaverse
in a ship that can go Interstellar but
it wouldn't even have to be fast because
they were Immortal anyway
probably no sense of time
David Jin says Star Trek proves they're
sexy aliens very Universe Spock in the
background knows what I'm talking about
yeah Spock was the original sexy alien
yeah yeah oh I would hit he was the main
heart all day long series that is so
[__] funny found out that the women
like Spock more than they like her
the dudes liked Kirk the women like
Spock I could have told them that that
was gonna happen yeah but they didn't
well I wasn't born then but I mean had I
been born then and old enough to for
them to ask me that question I would
have told them yeah
actually Laura our friend Laura she sent
me a Spock meme today on Facebook
because she Laura
is
uh she's younger than us she's
significantly younger than her
she recently discovered
the Spock thing the original series The
Original Series
I was talking to her at mannequins like
probably a couple months back
and she was like I just
watched like all the original Star Trek
Star Treks and she's like oh my god what
the [__] like Spock is like the sexiest
dude ever I was like right yeah and it's
like so we got into this whole
discussion about it and it was like so
funny that she just like [__] because
like I said she didn't see him when she
was grown up
and so so every now and then like she'll
say like on Facebook she'll send me like
some spot me because she knows like I'm
super into Spock too and I she feels
like no one else understands so when I
told her I was like oh I bro I totally
get it and [__] so now she sends me all
the [__] now because she likes it I
understand because nobody else seems to
understand
but obviously two people do understand
because like you said
even during the original run
uh you know female audiences responded
very favorably to spock and they made
him a bigger character yeah in the show
because I don't think they expect I
think they just expect him to be just
kind of like this minor character but
yeah this is who she's talking about
that's Laura where's my finger yeah
that's Laura that's Laura yeah and the
other one is Jen that's our other friend
yeah that's right yeah
I mean yeah so I and honestly I was
happy because I was kind of like oh my
God you discovered this the Spock fandom
the Spock love yeah he's my spirit
animal
you know Spock is
but
and we love the Mirror Universe spot but
I love regular Spock also yeah if you
guys know the mirror spot
you can go on YouTube and there's a mini
series on there I think it's got eight
or nine episodes It's called
um
Star Trek Continues you can watch it for
free there's Vic mignona Vic mignona
plays or mignona yeah it's his name I
think that's a plays Kirk and uh guy
named Todd haberkorn plays Spock and
it's a lot of the same writers from the
original series they have the dude that
plays Scotty was is Scotty's real son
they do this
yes and there's a
people show up you know all-star cast
you know show up to do Star Trek
Continues they don't do it anymore now
CBS told them they had to stop
but they have part two
of the [__] Mirror Universe of what
that Spock did after he sent Kirk back
to our universe and the revolution that
he kicked off
after the [__] Mirror Universe Kirk
got back on the ship it's a [__]
great it's called
uh fairest of them all the the original
the the first part in the original
series that was called Mirror Mirror and
that was called I think say called
Mirror Mirror and then you didn't watch
the original series fairest of them all
was the second part of that and man it's
[__] one of the best episodes in Star
Trek
it's not the original cast
it's the it's it's the they did a good
job they did a real good job it's just
filmed exactly like the old [__]
um same kind of writing just the quality
of the writing is really good I mean
they tried really hard to like replicate
the look and the tone yeah from like the
Earth The Originals because they were
really into it Gene roddenberry's son
saw the whole series oh yeah my dad
would have loved this this would have
been this is this is this would have
been I mean I can see that yeah it's the
final season
uh because the original series just
ended all right
and this well I got Star Trek Continues
they finally give it a final season and
the the last episode and it links up
with Star Trek the motion picture
to explain certain [__] that you see in
Star Trek the motion picture like why
did [__] Spock leave Starfleet why'd
he go back to Vulcan that's it explains
that what where the [__]
where do the new theme song came from
where do the new uniforms come from it's
all it's all in that yeah they filled in
like
that's what was cool about it yeah yeah
that was what was cool about right
well the thing about it is like
David Jean said what Spock is a sex
symbol oh absolutely yeah women like
Spock back in the day you're clearly not
a woman yeah you're not a woman but um
I'm not a woman either but I can
understand it well it was kind of like
the forbidden fruit see
he's he's the dude you can't have
the woman can't have him a woman could
get Kirk oh she just had to be hot
Star Trek Continues they addressed that
Kirk is cool I'm not saying that but um
you know in all iterations he's a cool
character but yeah I don't for some
reason like Spock was always like way
sexier to me but I mean I know I'm a
weirdo like I'm the person that was like
sexually attracted to Lurch from that
Adam's family so it's like you know me
so you know you can't listen to me too
much but [__] in Star Trek Continues
which is like I said it's the final
season of the [__] original series
okay done with an all-new cast that
loves Star Trek and The Descendants even
the Romulan female captain that Kirk was
[__] with
she comes back and is played by her
daughter the the daughter of the actress
and it looks just like her yeah she
looks just like that yeah because Kirk
had some [__] going on with the female
rhyming the captor he had a lot of
respect for it that shit's wrapped up
and then Kirk being a hoe and all the
women that died for Kirk in the series
yeah when we got run over because of him
you know what I mean [__] they
address all that [__] [__] um yeah
Kurt had to face the fact that yeah I
[__] over a lot of women in the
[__] first three days
to be fair [__] up a lot of women got
an answer for that [__] you know so he
does kind of spiritually uh answered for
it in a way
um he kind of has to come to terms with
the fact that he was a hoe
which kind of explains why he acted a
little bit better in the movies yeah he
would you know yeah it like Bridges
everything yeah Bridges all that
together I think the fact I think why I
always related to spock though
was because
um you know he's he's really super smart
and like all this other kind of stuff
but he doesn't really understand like a
lot of other people's emotions but the
thing about it I think people that don't
know a lot about Star Trek will be like
oh well Spock doesn't have emotions no
he does he actually he has like way
heightened emotions but Vulcans have
learned to like control them they
suppress their emotions because they
don't want like oh so I get that like I
think I related to having these horrible
like overwhelming emotions that you have
to like
you know consciously like work to
suppress yeah and I think that I kind of
like related to that I guess David June
is chiming in he loves Star Trek
Continues it's a [__] great I wanted
to get those things downloaded and do it
Blu-ray quality and print out because
they got all the [__] you can print out
all the artwork the covers for the
covers and everything I never got around
to doing it we need to do it because I
want them I want hard copies of them on
Blu-ray quality but um he's David June
talks about the Orion episode
yeah there's an episode there where an
Orion slave girl tried to escape and
they're uh from the orions and uh she's
trying to uh they're trying to help her
and trying to give her
[__] Asylum you know but the cat
because it violates a certain treaty
that they have and uh her slave master
[__] shows up to reclaim her and it's
Lou Ferrigno and he's like a loose
looking good man he's looking [__] he
was jacked as [__] probably in his 60s
he still look jacked as [__] death and
[__] when [__] he had a if you don't
if like Wesley's deaf he never really
learned how to talk but
other people that I know that are deaf
and when they talk they can talk but
they have that deaf accent that's the
only way you describe well because they
can't really quite hear what there's
they can't hear them yeah and he does it
but it he [__] pulls it off [__]
Lou pulls it off normally if the Lou was
when he was playing like Hercules and
[__] they dubbed him
but uh and then the Hulk he didn't say
anything which I I like the old Hulk
series I need to see that again
but no he doesn't yeah she's into that
when I was a kid yeah I liked it yeah my
cousin Wesley loved the Hulk he knew
that
uh he knew that Lou Ferrigno was deaf
yeah so he he was like that was a good
show I remember liking that job so I
haven't seen in a long time but I
remember liking it when I was a kid
thank you Jeffy art gave us a Super Chat
fun fact David kronenberg plays a
holographic therapist on Star Trek
Discovery yeah that's right I remember
that yeah Discovery was good too David
Cronenberg will show up in some movies
every now and then yeah as an actor and
look man a lot of you a lot of people
will [__]
God oh no I liked [__] uh Enterprise
that's with Scott Bakula and [__] uh
to Paul and [__] trip and everything
I liked it
and um
[__] uh [__] what was his name
Jeffrey Combs shows up to play shran
Commander schrand it was like
man [__]
shran and Cole there's another sexy
[__] yeah that was [__] great
I love Jeffrey Jones and in the end part
Enterprise had a kind of a spotty start
it got better as it went along then they
went to the temporal time War [__]
thread that was a good idea that they
just dropped because 9 11 happened so it
changed to something else and they were
like in the expanse for a while
um but they just and they had to just
end the series abruptly but it had two
of the best mirror episodes in a mirror
Darkly one and two and they're at the
end
you can't just jump in and see him
because
it's about the crew the Enterprise the
mirror crew of the Enterprise you have
to know the characters in the normal
Universe to understand how [__] up
they are in the second one like all the
[__] characters are like [__] makos
they're they're like they're they're
versing the Rangers they're tough as
nails and [__] they lie cheat steal try
to murder each other on the fight
and it it links in
within the original series
the episode where Kirk is getting
Vanishing he's like a ghost here but
thinks he's a ghost and he's in between
Dimensions that was because the thalians
were [__] around with space time
that's right well in the mirror Darkly
explains what the thalians were doing
they were stealing a [__] ship they
were stealing the defiant that's right
and they were taking it into the Future
No they were taking it into the past
in the past were trying to reach forward
into Kirks into the future where Kirk
was to steal a ship
and take it back to the past and they
were gonna try to sell all the
[__] technology off of it
but Scott Bakula from the past in the
Mirror Universe paid some criminals for
the information to find the fact the
fact that the thalians had stole that
ship and he was going to steal that ship
for the Empire so he could get promoted
and he does steal the ship
but then he realizes he's not going to
get promoted they're going to take the
ship from him and [__] keep his ass
[__] low ranking so he mutinies and
starts fighting the Terran Empire it's a
great episode two episodes [__] great
I was gonna say that the original the
original series The interesting thing
about the original series
is that I kind of feel like
um you know obviously they were uh you
know kind of gunning for Kirk to be the
main character
but then they were sort of surprised at
how people responded to
the other surrounding characters such as
Spock
and uh and what's his name doctor
yeah
we lost connection hold on it still says
zero
reconnection success okay reconnect you
reconnect are we back yeah I think
according to this we're back all right I
think
but uh yeah we lost our ship that
doesn't usually happen
but that's the weird thing I think that
I mean from a from a dude executive's
point of view I guess they're like well
obviously like Captain Kirk is like the
character that everyone's gonna respond
to but from my point of view it's like
Spock was obviously like the sex symbol
of the show Dr McCoy
I was a little more into Dr McCoy
there's a I I liked the whole
I liked how sarcastic he was I liked how
[__] cynical he was I just liked that
whole I mean the whole Triad was like it
wouldn't have worked without that
dynamic between the three that's my
favorite thing they were all very
different versions of masculinity right
you had Kirk who was very kind of like
um uh ambition he was about ambition and
power okay
[__] your basic male Alpha type trick
but still a good dude he wasn't like
like he he still had a moral compass
yeah it wasn't like and then you had
Spock
Spock was about logic okay and art if
you notice that he was big into art and
[__] logic and yeah see that's what that
was my wavelength yeah I really like
that and he was more uh reserved right
he wasn't so much and then you had McCoy
McCoy was about passion and Compact and
compassion human compassion and passion
just emotion you know like uh I like
that he was like he was kind of cynical
and kind of a smartass yeah but he was a
good dude but he would tell if like you
were saying some [__] [__] he would
absolutely tell you like right to your
face the thing was Jim how can you let
this happen how could you let this
happen yeah
I'm feeling [__] you know yeah so you
know I mean yeah like the dynamic
between the three of them was just like
a perfect yeah now David Jude comes in
and says the [__] Star Trek
Enterprise ruled until the [__] last
episode yes it did man they killed Tripp
and did all that [__] [__] up [__]
to try to wrap the episode up they
should have just let it hang they should
have said anything
because that [__] up any kind of
movies or anything else or any sequels
to it you know they just they [__]
that up they should have never made that
last episode that way they should have
done just a normal episode and just let
it end I don't remember what happened in
the last episode yeah man you showed it
to me a long time yeah they killed trip
they started some [__] with the
Federation the Federation was just
starting to form
um but no it just it just it wasn't any
good
uh they they the main problem is that
they killed trip they shouldn't have
done that
like I said I still go to I I would not
consider myself a Trekkie by any stretch
of the imagination but I'm really into
the Original Series yeah the other
series are good too if I've watched them
off and on but it's like I always go
back to the original series I will watch
those
[__] I'll watch the whole series and
then like a few months later it's like
let's watch the whole series again you
know what I mean I don't know I just
there's something about it I really like
yeah and like I said I don't think it's
just the spot character I think it's
Leonard Nimoy because I really like
Leonard Nimoy and like he kind of wrote
that character yeah I mean that that
character is largely his creation one of
the reasons one of the reasons why the
original series was so good and why Star
Trek lived on
is because they let the actors kind of
[__] do their own thing or write
their own characters as they went they
they had an input into the into the
characters especially the main guys in
the Triad
so and then they would did Scotty too
every now and then they do something
about Scotty yeah
yeah they did that Jack yeah and the
writers [__] liked liked the actors
and they liked the uh the characters and
they all just worked together it was it
evidently grew kind of organically
and um
you know
[__]
Shatner was like would read something in
a script because no my guy wouldn't do
that you know that's not what he would
do and they would change a script a
little bit
or no Kirk wouldn't say that because you
know the guys that are
playing these characters so I can know
him pretty well you know yeah they're
kind of merging with these characters
right you know so and so there was that
that Synergy between the writers and the
actors that [__] worked out real well
if you went and look at like Spock being
a Vulcan from the very pilot episode and
into the first parts of the of the first
season it's not real clear what a Vulcan
is
you find out more about a Vulcan because
because Leonard numoy's is making that
up and telling the writers no he should
be doing this he should be doing and
they they listened
so that's which is good like I said if
you have a TV show or a movie or
something like that I think it's very
important for the writers and the actors
to collaborate because it's a
collaborative process if you're writing
a novel you know that's just a writer's
thing you can do whatever but
if you're a writer and you're having a
person portray a character that you
wrote
they're gonna bring their own energy to
it so you really have to like listen to
their feedback as well to like make it
work as well as it could possibly work I
feel like yeah I mean you know
considering if you got the right actor
obviously yeah but I kind of feel like
Leonard Nimoy I mean that's his
character yeah other like other people
have played it and played it
successfully I thought but
I mean he was the one that really
originated yeah that and I don't know
if you could ever I mean you can't
really get anybody to like replace him
there would not have been a Spock
without letter Nimoy that the the spot
character that you know would not have
evolved with that the way into what you
know of his Spock I mean did they
initially I kind of feel like maybe they
initially pictured Spock as just a
person really well he was going to be
like the token alien I guess and he was
just gonna be like oh we're he's gonna
be like the robotic emotionless
character and he's gonna be like maybe
like funny situations
the pilot episode he's showing emotions
don't you remember yeah that's true he's
smiling and laughing now he's a totally
different character they didn't know
what a vocal was they they kind of had
to make that up as they were going
because I mean what a Vulcan was is
really as an orthodox Jew that's what it
is
rebooted all right but you know that
that's
yeah a lot of his culture yeah
is taking Judaism and re-molding it and
rebooting it into an alien culture into
like a Sci-Fi yeah yeah that's what he's
doing like I said it worked out really
yeah it was a great idea it worked out
really well and like I said it it gave
that character like such
depth like I said it would be one thing
to have the character just be like kind
of robotic and it's like oh it's funny
that they don't understand humans
um and he had a little bit of that but I
like that they added the dynamic of you
know Vulcans being like overly emotional
it's like we had to learn how to like
control our emotions so it's like we're
always like suppressing them so there
was always kind of like this push and
pull and I really really liked that
Dynamic I think it lent a lot of um you
know the Vulcans had cousins living on
another planet who didn't adopt that
they were the Romulus right they they
were they could interbreed you know and
they were basically the same thing oh
they were just they were just only a
little bit different
so somebody mentioned originally the
Vulcans are supposed to be real violent
well they they did deliver that in the
story just yeah they put that on the on
the Romulus and the Ramones were good
too they weren't bad they were just
Violet they were warlike but they were
good people they had good characters
in the whole series you know even the
rhyming the cat they had honor they
weren't just you know Savages but the
same thing was for the for the Klingons
they were like that too
even though they weren't really quite
sure what a Klingon was until much later
the Klingon was just a damn kind of just
generic bad guy for a while
then they flesh that yeah I mean that's
the thing with like and it particularly
TV shows from back then I kind of feel
like now they try to at least kind of
have a direction because they know
people are a lot pickier nowadays than
they used to be this was original but
this is the original attempted World
building right you know yeah so I feel
like this wasn't really I mean it wasn't
really as common as it is now so it's
just kind of like well they didn't know
how long the show was going to be on
they just wanted some people to watch it
so they could sell some gains burgers or
whatever so it's just kind of like we're
not thinking about it all that like
they're thinking about it obviously but
I don't think they're thinking about it
all that hard you know what I'm saying
so and then like we don't know if we're
gonna be on next season right and then
like next season oh you got renewed and
it's like well [__] now we gotta like
[__] work out all this stuff you know
what I mean so a lot of the stuff was
sort of
they came up with it on the fly but in
in the case of that it did really kind
of like work out
I feel like it's mostly consistent
mostly I mean you do kind of see
differences between in the characters
between the earlier episodes and later
ones but
they kept it like fairly consistent I
thought yeah as much as possible that's
right Dave says they killed Tripp on
that last one to turn the whole series
into it they had Riker from the Next
Generation and he was doing it through
the Holodeck yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
that's [__] yeah I forgot about that
and then uh Jeffrey Jeffy art says Star
Trek Deep Space Nine is his absolute
favorite I haven't seen all the episodes
but every episode of Deep Space Nine I
saw I liked it with Benjamin Cisco I
don't know if I don't think I've seen
any of this face and I now that I'm
thinking about it yeah and then I saw
the part where they got the damn little
ship what was it the defiant
or was it what was the name of that they
had a little bitty Battleship that they
were using for a couple missions there
towards the end it was pretty neat I
think it might have been the defied or
it might have been the Reliant
but uh yeah you know trying to nerdy ass
Trekkie [__] but it was good you know
[__] on nerds yeah nerdy ass tricky [__]
you get nerdy about stuff and it's like
but you but somehow it's not dirty when
you do it my favorite Star Trek
character really besides Spock of all
times would have been shran command uh
Commander sharan well and specifically
because he was played by Jeffrey yeah I
mean how can you not live Jefferson but
Jeffrey Collins also played that Jim
Hadar guy yeah the gem a dark clone he'd
get killed every time he'd come back
later because they were clear thousands
and millions of them
I forgot what his name ability to get
Jeffrey Combs yeah
it's so awesome if he'd like do a
Sidetrack show with us and like sit
around and get drunk and we could talk
about we could talk about like [__]
reanimator we could talk about all the
Lovecraft movies he did and that's like
that we could talk about The Frighteners
that would be so [__] cool he's so
[__] awesome
ah
thank you David June live long and
prosper [__] yeah right
I mean I don't know what it is I'm just
maybe I'm weirdo
but I was always like if like I said my
my first Chris was my first crush when I
was a kid was
Lurch from Adam's Family
played by Ted Cassidy
I don't know why that's just one of the
things but I mean I don't know
I like Spock because he was just always
so he was just so eminently reasonable
and he was just always like look you
[__] it's like but you know
blah blah and I'm like yeah right
tell them you know he's like he's always
right about everything and everybody get
all pissed off about it it's like you
know what I mean
uh Jeff here said it's hard to keep the
lore straight after 50 years yeah you
know
it's
to be honest I'm kind of
it kind of blows me away that a show
like that or like any kind of like
extended intellectual property
that has a lot of people working on it
like over a long extended period of time
it always like blows my mind that
anybody can keep all that [__] straight
that they keep it all like as consistent
as they keep it so I'm pretty forgiving
like if somebody [__] up something like
a little thing like every now and then
because I'm like
[__] I'm just like one person and I've
written novels and I've written novels
that are like 200 pages and I'm sure
I've like contradicted myself it's
harder than you think it is and
especially like when you have like
multiple people working on things like
over multiple Generations like something
like Star Trek for Christ's sake which
has this you know really rich like
background more that you have to kind of
consider like every time you're writing
about something so the fact that they're
able to keep it as consistent as they've
kept it is pretty admirable I think you
know what I mean
uh Jeffy Hart said yeah it was the
defiant the defiant yeah
I don't think I saw any of Deep Space
Nine I mean if I did I don't remember it
you showed me Enterprise I remember that
um and I saw most of next generation
and what was the other one
yeah that's right Jeffy Harris got him
he knows the series is real well
comes played vorta
vorta way home one of the best billions
ever that's right
that was wait a minute hold on was
Florida the name of the guy who was the
gem hodar
remember he'd make them all pray before
he gave him the [__] drugs that they
had to sniff
he'd make sure they were hatching and he
and the Jim madaro had this religion and
they only lived to be like eight before
they died
but they were just these bad asses
he lived a long time and he was kind of
like the the overseer of the of these
little units and he was a clone they
they had millions of them
he kind of scoff and laugh at their
little religion while he was giving them
all their little drugs and [__] because
they gave him basically kind of like
some pleasure drugs to keep him under
control
and they would hatch and they'd be fully
grown in in a few weeks and they could
put them on duty and fly ships and
[__] they're real good at combat but
they never they didn't live long if I
remember correctly they were they only
lived to be like eight I think eight or
nine or something
I don't remember
you guys would probably remember better
than me because I don't I didn't see all
those episodes
what's the matter Pokey
oh she comes like yeah trundling over
here she's like what are you guys called
did those clones all have the same name
I guess they did huh
the Clones of Jeffrey Combs
look at all they should clone Jeffrey
Combs
I was saying while you were in the
bathroom I said we need to get that
[__] on the show he'd probably
get him on a show he doesn't get drunk
with us yeah he drinks when he's when he
comes on when he comes on shows he just
drinks on them
and you can ask him questions and [__]
he talks about his old rolls I could
probably talk him into it he seems kind
of awesome wear something real low cut
and contact
I want to talk about him [__] doing
shran and [__] all his Star Trek like
I said can we talk about like you know
he's probably sick of talking about that
[__] probably probably sick of talking
about reanimator
well maybe we could ask them about
Frighteners don't ask them about
Frighteners yeah he likes that movie
he's Lieutenant Danvers he's [__]
great enough yeah he's so weird I love
it yeah he's kind of sexy too not gonna
lie
Dave is telling to watch strange new
worlds thing is I'm not gonna subscribe
to CBS to watch to watch that [__] I
heard Strange World New World just okay
but
I heard [__] uh Star Trek Discovery
STD I heard that's terrible
uh that it doesn't make any that damn
sense that whoever wrote that doesn't
even know the original series
but I think all that shit's canceled STD
got canceled I believe
STD STD they're people making fun of it
they've made it Star Trek Discovery STD
they know that [__] shrekies [__]
abbreviate all that [__] STD that's [__]
that's a sexual transmitted disease man
yeah
they should have never called it that
maybe they were going for the Streisand
Effect they don't know they don't they
didn't know the fandom I don't think
I don't know maybe I don't know I
haven't seen it yeah I don't know I
don't overestimate CBS and their ability
to hire people they had a [__] ton of
money and they blew it none of that [__]
made any money they could they should
have [__] hired [__] Vic and the
guys from Star Trek Continues well
everybody said that they just should
have done that okay and done there they
could have had a whole series of [__]
[__] that happened in between
Star Trek emotion pitcher and wrathicon
there was several years worth of [__]
that could have happened right there
they could have had five [__] seasons
a [__] spot yeah I mean there's so
much like open Kirk right
with with the people from from Star Trek
Continues with a higher budget and it
should have looked like wrathicon
in terms of the uniforms that era it
would have been great it'd have been
great because [__] Vic can't do Kirk
to me Vic mignona is Kurt that's another
Kirk I accept him as Kirk
Jeff here said the Dominion was the main
bad guys the changelings were the leader
slash God the gemfadar were the soldiers
yeah the vorta were the diplomats and
facilitators okay
I don't okay I didn't I don't remember
exactly how how all that [__] was the
one that
Combs was playing what the diplomats he
played anything that wasn't a gem hedar
I know they were a whole damn species of
clones that they were all cloned to do
certain things
and the gym hidar didn't live very long
I think they only lived about eight
eight years I think
Jeffy art said the Dominion were from
the other side of the Galaxy yeah yeah
it's been a long time since I've seen
that [__]
I just it was good though but I was in
the Army at the time so I didn't get to
see them all
the ones I did see were reruns I need to
get that whole series
one of these days which probably like
sit down and watch all like The
Originals here like watch them all like
in chronological or anything yeah but I
like to Deep Space Nine it was good and
it took me a while to warm up to Cisco
but eventually I was like yeah this is
pretty cool because he seemed like a
dick when I first started watching it
but I really liked Voyager with Captain
oh that was the other one that I was
trying to yeah which it was good yeah
I've seen some of that too Voyager was
more like Star Trek like Star Trek with
with carcasses Deep Space Nine was
happening on a [__]
Space Station
outside this Wormhole that would appear
every now and then weird [__] would
happen there
and they had a lot of it was kind of
soapy in a certain way they had a damn
Ferengi guy who ran to them he was cool
but he ran the local uh bar and uh his
brother his little brother who was this
Diggy looking [__] freaky guy who's
Dopey as [__] hooks up with this really
badass [__] blonde human chick
and that's his girlfriend and there's
like a total mismatch it's kind of a
comedy thing but all kinds of weird [__]
happens with him
it was good series I just didn't get to
see it all
but every episode I saw was good it was
satisfying
Jeff here I said sorry I have three
guinnesses in me and my Uber nerd is
starting to get crazy with the keyboard
yeah don't apologize we it's we're we're
all nerds here yeah
it's fine
you can nerd out about anything you want
yeah that said
um I think I really need to go to sleep
yeah yeah
I'm starting to like kind of be like oh
my god I think I'm gonna doze off like
I'm like yeah I just go like that then
nobody wants to see that nobody just
wants to watch a live stream of me
sleeping on my keyboard go ahead hit
that like button people if you can we've
got 17 likes that's good we've only got
15 people we [__] bled off a lot of
the temp talking about his [__] Star
Trek we lost like the lyrics are coming
out bye
too nerdy that's all right yeah that's
all right we gotta leave yes come on
gotta love the Nerds uh but yeah so
we'll see well like um
here's the thing I don't know are we
gonna go out tomorrow night yeah
so we're not gonna have time to watch a
movie then
and look well I guess we could watch a
movie during the day we could watch a
movie during the day yeah so we'll try
to do a movie review on Sunday and we'll
do like a live stream on Sunday probably
at 6 00 p.m EST to like you know just
keep it kind of
early enough in the day are you leaving
for good yeah I'm leaving oh okay okay
well I didn't know I didn't know if you
were just running off to the bathroom no
I'm good good but yeah so uh yeah it's
getting late I've haven't had that much
sleep over the last couple days so I'm
getting really really tired I wanna
relax in bed for a minute eat a small
Debra
a small Deborah yeah and uh you know
maybe watch this you got a new
girlfriend
[Laughter]
bad girl you
no I just started calling them a small
Deborah because it sounds like classier
yeah it's been a little Debbie
last year
yeah so we'll be back on Sunday talking
about movie I don't know what one it's
gonna be but uh whatever one we decide
to watch tomorrow so hopefully you guys
can join us thank you everybody for
dropping by thank you for super chats
and we will see you again on Sunday
evening good night